okay I I guess we'll get started with
our first
subcommittee uh meeting of the morning
which is uh related to House Bill 437
relative to a reading assessment in
Intervention
Program um I think pretty much uh the
entire subcommittee is here and um a few
um uh Spectators as well
um uh so I I think where we left off
last time um there was a couple of
things um that were mentioned at the end
of the last meeting um and one was that
we were going to have another conference
call with um Dr uh Carol Tolman who is
um one of the authors of the letters
program um and um an
international um uh
leader in terms of literacy she's been
to I found out China and
Australia um leading discussions about
literacy um so um we did have that
conversation and um Melissa white of the
department who was here was was part of
that call um and I think uh I think it
went well um generally supportive of of
what's in this document and Dr Coleman
um was um glad to see the addition of um
the uh assessment for uh teachers um
renewing their certification so that um
they also get uh up to speed in terms of
um uh the evidence-based
literacy um direction that um we are
headed um and I think we also um I think
representative luno also you mentioned
um going through uh this the bill
section by section uh pretty much and um
so this current handout and I've
got um more copies for those in the
audience um I've labeled some of the uh
areas you know one through I think nine
um so we can go through each of those is
is there a difference between what you
distributed last week
uh just one minor one um the only
addition you'll see it uh with an arrow
there um uh local school district and
chartered public school on um right by
the number one on the first page
oh um that's pretty much what's what's
being done now but um I think the
suggestion was to uh specify it in here
so that's what uh I did
okay so um the uh first
section um is related to the uh um
Universal
screener um and the major change there
is that um two that uh this would be a a
state supplied uh screener and that it
would be given three times times um a
year um which is
uh recommendations from a number of
experts and people in the field here in
New Hampshire um as well um and we had
it discussion that um this state
screener um could be supplemented um I
know a number of teachers who talk to
reading Specialists um give more
frequent um
assessments um based on the individual
student and where they are so this is
not um one and done type of uh uh
requirement um that there just be three
assessments um and we've also talked to
the department and the feeling is that
um there might be funds available for
the purchase and training and support of
ace Statewide screener for all the
districts uh but probably not more than
that um so if the uh if we wanted the um
Department to provide the screener um
you know there would probably be only
one um one uh that could be funded um
and this would probably be from uh
federal
funds
so can I ask it a question
we're rolling on this when you say that
one could be funded what what does that
mean and what does that limitation imply
um that um one universal screener could
be funded um probably through federal
funds by the department because of the
cost they they would probably not have
funds available to provide more than one
uh screener for the districts especially
if we wanted to um include um the
training in the field and support for
the field people in the field
okay
um and I'll just mention that a lot of
the um areas you'll see um have uh
sections included in
italics and those are uh specifically uh
recommendations that uh came from um
from the department and from Dr tol in
terms of um what we should be um looking
at so that's what the uh difference is
for the areas in
italics
um if we go over to page
two um you'll see a Roman 3 section I
labeled number two um and this um uh
requires or this um
uh is geared toward uh the um progress
monitoring and instructional Services uh
to be provided um when there is a
deficiency um identified in the
Universal screener or another uh
screener uh locally used um in the
district
um and um that the progress that the
student is making should be monitored on
a fairly regular basis uh to see if um
uh interventions that are being put in
place are actually um having the desired
effect um also in this section in um f
um we say that the three queing method
that is currently being used in a number
of
districts um should not be re be used
and they should be moving toward the
evidence-based um reading um and I'll
mention here that um this this whole
thing really is a follow on to what the
department has already been doing over
the past couple of years in terms of um
I think the program um Melissa correct
me if wrong if I'm wrong but is it
called a love of
reading okay
right um plus the um letters training
that is being uh offered um and um last
I heard it was over 3,000 people um
including teachers parents and even
grandparents who are um getting involved
with that training in um this
evidence-based science of reading um
literacy um uh
program which I which um the people from
letters u even um mentioned that uh New
Hampshire is far ahead of other states
in terms of um getting people involved
in the letters training um especially uh
parents and uh others um beyond the uh
School staff um we're far ahead of other
states in that regard
Glen yes sir uh I'm not even sure I'm on
the subcommittee but I could ask that's
okay sure uh where you are on F under uh
three uh second page that talks about
the uh 3 queing system of reading and
visual
memory I'm I'm uncomfortable with a
group of legislators who have no
background in Reading making decision
for people who actually have information
about this and I that one I see is a
local control local school board
decision to make uh so I've been I've
been there for a long time I've been
really really open about that I'm
uncomfortable with with us saying to a
local school board or system you should
do this I'm more uncomfortable with
something like this is where says you
shall not do this uh I think it's an
inappropriate role for this committee to
to uh take that particular stand and I
I'm not I'm not cognizant of of uh all
the details around the various
approaches but just seems as a report as
a way of getting at this I I just have
problems with the concept that's all I
uh I wouldn't be interested in other
members of the committee commenting on
that oh let me mention that um this has
been reviewed by
um experts around the
country um and um we would not be the
first state to say no more uh three
queing um method of instruction of
literacy because um it doesn't we've
seen that it doesn't work it doesn't
work it doesn't reflect um how uh kids
learn to read um and um states around
the country I think it's something like
uh 18 states in the past few years have
moved away from this type of reading
instruction to the evidence-based
science of reading um method of
instruction because it's based on really
research
on how um the brain functions in
learning how to read
um so I I think that um it's important
that we uh
um uh if you want to say put a stake in
the ground and say we have to move to
something that evidence has shown will
work you know when our state average for
um uh Ela proficiency is uh below 50% um
I think we have to go in a different
direction and I think here we are moving
in a proven um Direction um by experts
um here in New Hampshire
um as well as around the country have
said um you know this is the direction
we should go if we want to improve
literacy okay thank you so Glenn yes
sir so thanks I I I'm not sure that's
what what um what art was really getting
at here it's not so much a um a a debate
or an objection of of of of
um you know one you know the the the
letters program or evidencebased reading
but but but more of the we're now
placing the state in a position where
we're where we're mandating a certain
form of of instruction um uh you know so
I'm not an expert in instruction but but
I've I've um you know hung around people
that that are and and for example in in
mathematics there's a um there's you
know you know there's a thing called
intuitive math that helps people become
better at doing math so should we
require intuitive math instruction at at
the second grade level to improve our Ma
I mean where where does it end I guess
is is is is the question I think that's
what what what art was was saying here
and and that and that we do have um
experts um um you know such as Dr
cascaden um you know leading the the
Berlin School District um um uh you know
in hopkington it with Steve Chamberlain
when I was on on the school board and
then uh of course you've got certified
teachers credential teachers that uh
that are experts in these areas too and
one of the one of the concerns I would
have in in in
um Part F which I think is what art was
looking at so so this is a shall not so
what if a what if a teacher
does um you know does does that you know
what's what's the enforcement mechanism
that the department would use to um um
to apply right U you know in paragraph
that and U yeah thank thank you for that
question um yeah there is no um uh
penalty or enforcement mechanism in here
I think it's it's more of a statement of
Direction um there's no um uh date set
that as of um you know December 1st U
you shall not use um this uh system of
of reading um it's a a statement that we
want to uh move in this direction and um
District should be moving in this
direction anyway based on all the
efforts of the Department of of
education um and this is just putting it
into statute that um we need to move
away from this this method there is no
penalty involved so so thanks for that
clarification but in section three um
the bottom of of paragraph Roman I uh it
says the Department of Education shall
adopt rules 541a concerning reading
interventions which is which is that
that exact thing and and those rules
would be able to include things such as
um um as disciplinary actions uh against
against teachers wouldn't they um yeah
I'm I'm not sure if we have rules that
include um uh disciplinary actions um
but um those all um I I see someone uh
um Melissa would you like to
uh
okay yes representative yeah I'm not on
the committee either as AR alluded to he
may not be on it either
but but you know where I'm coming from I
I think the the whole idea this this uh
methodology for instructing and teaching
reading has a place in our
schools I I tend to still go back to who
has the responsibility for curriculum
and instruction we clearly state in
statute that that's a local
decision um so when we when we say that
you shall not do
something it's like when we had this hot
debate years ago when it came to Modern
math or common core math there are
really Divergent groups on on on both
the sides of the coin and um it to say
this is how we're going to Mary is
reading along and all of a sudden doing
a great job all a sudden bang she
doesn't understand the word there so
then the teacher then tries to identify
and offer some uh instructional skills
or ideas of how that what that word may
be um I I think that is a decision that
has has to be made based upon the
instruction they've learned in the prep
schools and all that you know
Preparatory colleges on on uh how to
teach reading as we're staying within
saying in this bill that's good but
there's a lot of other ways too and I
saw too many times in the past where
we've been told no classrooms going to
have no walls no they're going to have
walls no we're going to teach inquiry
oriented science with skiss and ESS and
all the other programs that came out at
that time and then we're going to go
into modern math and then we realize oh
the kids can't identify a difference
between a number and a numeral we're
going to go into Common Core MTH and the
pendulum swings so much in
education that um sometimes we we let it
get out of control and we end up our
teachers end up becoming managers not
instructors and so I I I app applaud the
bill I think we need to go that
direction however I don't think we
should say no to any particular way of
teaching um so that's where where I'm
coming from I I think there is a measure
of local control and responsibility for
that that lies with the specific
district and with that classroom teacher
in the
classroom um Melissa would you like to
come up and talk
about the uh direction of the department
is taken in this
regard oh right you repeat
yes um yeah shall not uh employ the
three
Q queing from the way I read that I can
turn that on if that helps from the way
that I read this is in regards to the
students that do not pass is that
correct the screening so we're talking
at the most at risk students the
students who are flagged as needing the
most Intervention which would normally
mean that we would want to give them a
intervention that is reliable and proven
to work with students um so when we look
at that we're looking at longitudinal
data that shows that it has worked in
variety of school settings to make sure
that the students can improve and Excel
in learning how to read so the way in
which I'm read I don't read it that it's
removing it from all schools but
removing it from the students who were
flagged most at
risk which is a different type of of
level we're talking about kids who are
not breaking the code in reading and
phenology spelling does that help answer
the
question uh representative
lak even the person who first came up
with the 3 queing system has
more recently said it doesn't work
people shouldn't be doing it and there's
evidence that if you're trying to te do
both 3 queing and other methods the 3
queing is even harmful in conjunction it
not only doesn't work it interferes with
actually
learning and that doing both should not
be an option because doing both is still
harmful that's right and I think you're
refering resarch says yes is um uh
Columbia University um School of uh um
teacher preparation um has uh um
terminated the uh division that uh used
or was based on the Lucy cins method of
uh instruction which is um basically the
three queing
method so and and as was pointed out um
this is
um section three which is where this is
the intervention where there has been a
deficiency
identified uh many
yes so you know and I I I I I apologize
for always leaning on my time on the
school board but and I can see Becky
sort of you know laugh on on that a
little bit because um she we worked
together at Hopkinson when I was on the
board um but um but you know I'm I'm I'm
familiar with the term you know um you
know response to intervention RTI and
intervention um
uh and and I I I seem to recall a lot of
professional development being directed
towards uh towards this area um for um
for you know for teachers and I guess we
you know we've got we've got credential
teachers in in all of our
schools
um that would know I think about about
the the differences and the interactions
between the queuing system and and um
and a a and I'm I'm missing the term not
phonics but uh but a um awareness what
is it phic awareness phic awareness type
uh type system but are are we you know
is the concern that that that we don't
have trained Professionals in our
classrooms that need to have statute
direct how they provide instruction
or I I mean I guess is that the concern
that we don't have trained teachers in
in classroom so we need to have statute
that directs instruction uh I I think
that there are many um uh teachers and
reading Specialists who are trained in
the new um evidence-based science of
reading um based on letters and based on
actually um uh newly certified or uh
licensed teachers um take an assessment
called knowledge of reading um which is
based on this new method of reading um
and that's why in here we also add for
teachers renewing they should have that
assessment um under their belts also um
so that we know that they are um all
moving in the in this Direction that's
the the idea is in this is to move in
that direction because we need to do
something to improve our literacy so
aren't you just saying that we're
already moving in that
direction uh I think that's the
Department's uh Direction
yes and and our and our districts are
moving in that direction some not all is
my understanding from from talking to
people in the
field
okay
um there is
um well I'll leave it at that I don't
want to get into the the money angle of
things um but do you have any further uh
comments on that no I think that's about
right the districts are all over the map
some of them are switching some of them
are still in um different program we did
conduct a survey that showed that a
variety were using um fondon panel and
Lucy ckins and so I know that there's
been a shift and we did offer the
Leaning into literacy Grant um and
provided schools with resources and
funding to help shift if they wanted to
apply thank you um
uh
yes thank
you so
I am concerned and trying to
anticipate what happens going forward if
if this legislation were to
pass and I think we probably can all
agree that education is ongoing and how
children learn whether it's learning to
read or learning math or whatever what
we think today is different than what we
thought at various different times in
the past and the programs for different
curriculums keep changing so if we were
to put this in place and then we learn
differently about
reading we are saying to districts you
can't change until we legislate another
state
imposed approach to teaching
reading as opposed to respecting that
license trained education professionals
care so much about kids that they will
continue to evolve and Implement what is
the current understanding of how
children learn it's not
static so the question part of that is
what what would a district do if this
were in place and it no longer made
sense in the knowledge of the
day well what we're talking about here
with evidence-based science of reading
is based on decades Decades of
research um it's not something that has
popped up in the past uh two or three
years um um there's been brain studies
done as looking at sections of the brain
and how children actually um comprehend
and uh develop comprehension and
identification of um the words that
their reading um so this is not um
something that's uh just sprung up this
is Decades of research that um has not
been um
really pushed forward until the past um
I don't know uh you five 10 years maybe
um for various factors one is because of
the publishing industry
um um so I I think that we're not we're
doing something here that is based
solidly on evidence and um scientific
evidence um in terms of brain research
um so um will there be more research
done um in the future uh probably um but
also one of the um things in this Bill
also is that the uh department is to
provide
guidance to um local districts in terms
of instructional materials that um uh
should be used so we're we're trying to
leverage um Everybody into this process
um from the Department to the districts
to the parents to the communities to
libraries um we need U everyone to try
and um move forward in terms of
improving literacy um in this state and
it's it's being done around the country
um so you know we're not uh we're not
leading the pack on this um uh um you
know maybe we should have been but um
what we're trying to do is uh move it
forward based on decades literally of
research follow
up
thank
you I'm trying
to put this in useful
language there are Decades of research
in I think any aspect of brain function
and
Science and we keep
learning and when we learn if I fall
back to my roots in dietetics nutrition
work people would complain you keep
changing your mind eggs are good eggs
are bad eggs are good which is it it's
not changing your mind it's learning and
responding to the
new ongoing studies and reflecting that
in the recommendations that are
made so I'm uncomfortable with
saying this may I don't know I'm not a
reading expert this may well be the best
way to teach reading
today but putting it into law means
we're saying it's the best way to teach
reading in perpetuity and that doesn't
make sense to me fite your thoughtful
explanation um I would just comment that
we're not mandating any
curriculum um and even the department is
huh I'm sorry I didn't mean to blur out
but I said yes we are because it looks
to me like we're mandating a curriculum
what what is this if it isn't a
curriculum it's a method of instruction
um we had disc with the Department about
uh curriculums and um instructional
materials and we decided the best course
of action was for the Department just to
recommend instructional materials not
mandate some states actually have a list
of curriculum that is allowed to be
taught in um in schools in their state
um and we're not we didn't want to head
in that direction because of local
control we just want a curriculum um
instruction materials that are based on
this new um or decades old research that
has been done um that's that's only
where we're going it's not mandating any
specific curriculum we purposely um
avoided going down that
path representative
lakas yeah I just wanted to respond to
about what rep luno said and and in the
more recent conversation
um yes teachers are certified and
trained the problem is what they were
certified and trained in because 3
queing was big for a long time and there
are a lot of teachers that's what they
were taught and that's what they're
teaching and as the doe
found some schools are still using it in
spite of the fact that it's been shown
that it doesn't work and in spite of the
fact that even the person who developed
it said it doesn't work and she has kind
of recanted what she was doing because
she realizes it doesn't work we have
lots of evidence now years's worth that
it doesn't work so that's why we're
saying not to use it but yes there are
still school districts that are using it
and that's why we're saying you can't
but the other
part it says evidenced based reading
instructional program it doesn't that
the evidence changes that will change
because it's
not use this book use this curriculum
whatever it's
use use a curriculum that's based on
science and evidence so if the evidence
changes that should change as well we're
not specifying what to give it that
flexibility to say as we learn more we
will change what we're doing
and as we learn more well what have we
learned we learn three queing doesn't
work so we're saying we're not going to
do that we're saying we're going to use
evidence-based
materials well that will change as
evidence changes so it's it's not
specific repres I'd like to ask Melissa
you're sitting there listening to all
this I do have a question for you that
uh from your perspective of working at
doe and interacting with school
districts um in the amendment that I'm
looking at it's a little different but I
think it's the same language and
everything that you're talking about
here upon doing the screening in grades
K through three or grades 1 through
three kindergarten grades 1 through
three and if a child is identified as
needing support in
reading the it says shall be given
intensive and I need to know what
intensive means means and general
education reading intervention I need to
know what general education means in
terms of does it mean at the local level
that you're going to have a remedial
reading teacher get involved are you
going to have the classroom teacher now
having another group are you going to
break kids up into high middle low like
sometimes we do in
mathematics um and that intervention
must start within 10 days uh so there
there's three things there which I'm
really concerned about I need to have
what you mean by
intensive who intensive you know might
be different in District a and certainly
different in
C um but we're mandating that this
occur yeah so what we're thinking is
what we would call mtss or the three
tier system so once a student is
identified they will get additional
support in reading and you're correct it
will look very different depending on
the school systems some school systems
have pair of professionals who are
trained to do that some school districts
have Title One teachers which is a
federal program some school districts
use their reading teachers depending on
um the way that the test results come
out so once the test results come out
schools should have data meetings to
discuss what levers do we have inside
the school to provide that support for
that child and it can look very
different but the idea is that the top
gets um so when you asked about General
ad that's the teacher in the classroom
so the top gets the teacher and then
they get an additional layer and you
could have groups um that has been done
where a kid will rotate to different
teachers um inside the classroom to get
different levels of support but you want
to use the data to guide the support
right if the students don't know their
letters and sounds that's where you want
to start a group that targets that skill
if the students don't have phic
awareness you start a group for that if
the students need help and comprehension
you start a group with that way so
you're meeting the needs of the students
in front of you um tier two can even
occur inside the general classroom
depending on how that classroom is set
up so a teacher could take a group right
and give them extra help inside their
classroom as well so you're right
there's a varied landscape across um New
Hampshire's Educators and it really
depends on how the schools um can use
those levers inside their school and may
I follow up sure and and does it depend
Melissa upon of course there are a lot
of variables you know we have rural
schools very small we have City Schools
which are very large and may have some
support internally in their curriculum
departments um are we talking yes
there's Grant programs but we've seen
grants are here today and gone tomorrow
and then when we hire folks to uh teach
these areas and the grant disappears
then you have this uproar internally
within the district oh you're going to
I'm going to lose Mrs Smith here who's
excellent teacher but there's no no
source of Revenue coming in to support
that salary so then you either looking
at local property taxes going up um my
concern is I guess a number of issues
right here that you know the the
classroom teachers I know are very
effective in to a degree that are some
students as we see even in special
education where the kid needs to be
pulled because there is a specific IEP
need we're going to start seeing that
and there's going to be some costs
associated with that and the small
District certainly is not going to have
a small school of 70 kids in it k
through eight may not have that support
system internally within the school so
how do they how are they going to be
able to uh comply with this all
legislation um where you're going to
have to get this reading intervention
and it's going to have to be intensive
well I don't think that that's any
different than the recent legislation
law that you guys just passed for the
dyslexia screener because technically if
the students are flagged in the dyslexia
screener the school must provide um
intervention that is
evidence-based so it actually does not
change um that in any shape or form
because the current dyslexia screener
says You must provide that EV
evidence-based instruction so our
schools are already working on plans to
support kids who are struggling reading
um and I'm getting lots of calls on that
and there's a lot of different ideas
that they've come up with but they are
really trying to support the students um
that are
flagged I don't doubt that they're
trying to support I I know they're
trying to do that that I I I guess my
questions go to you know where's the
wherewithal coming to do that and what
kind of organizational changes are they
having to do with their staff internally
to ensure that this occurs with that
class of 20 kids now you have maybe five
kids or three kids that need this
intervention
um there's only so many hours in a day
and there's only that much of a teacher
that can be split apart and so um that
that's a concern okay if if I could just
um read from 377 which we passed last
year the student School District shall
provide age appropriate evidence-based
intervention strategies to begin by
January 1st of the school year for any
student who is identified as having
characteristics that are associated with
potential indicators or risk factors of
Dyslexia and Related Disorders so that's
that's in statute now as as you point
out it doesn't say
intensive strategy so this says intens
ensive and that that's a word that I I
think it's a lawyer's
dream so Glenn yes I'm glad you brought
up um um uh House Bill 377 that was
passed earlier this year uh it it
literally just went into effect four
weeks ago so I don't think we've got any
data coming com from this and and makes
sense to me at least that that we should
we should see how how
377 um you know takes off you know over
the next you know 12 24 months and um
and and we should see some some positive
you know you know fruits from that fruit
from that work that uh that this
committee uh did recently on that but um
my my my question to you though really
sort of I think you know tails off what
what Rick was um was asking and
something you mentioned ear earlier that
um that did you say that the department
has a grant right now um to help
districts um we better trained and we
did have a grant they are looking at
whether they're going to reinstate that
um we used essr funds to um provide 25 I
believe maybe even 35 schools um funding
for materials it was
um you had to submit we had there was a
whole rubric involved and so they are
evaluating whether that might be another
opportunity again in the future to
continue to provide um some materials
for school systems so so um do you
recall how much um in the aggregate that
that S Grant was and and did you say it
was for 35 districts received I can tell
you right away as I'm writing a report
no that'd be great is there another
question in the meantime well well yeah
I mean so the the um the the the
question I'd be getting to is is um is
you know are would we be better off um
using this bill as a vehicle to um to
help continue that Grant and rather than
it being a competitive Grant be a grant
that's really directed to the schools
that we now know um uh are um maybe need
additional support to to to move off um
you know a queuing method towards
towards new methods um that was the
direction my original bill was headed um
but I felt that after the bill did not
get passed last year when we had the
budget available to us to try and
Implement um um a grant related to um
children with uh
deficiencies based on children number of
children deficiencies and a plan for
addressing those facilities I thought it
might be uh too much of a cost to try
and put forward in a non-budget year so
that's why we decided to go with the
compe competitive Grant scenario but um
we put in a time frame for that t uh
competitive Grant so that in the next
budget we could revisit that and my hope
is that we could move to a um a larger
Grant process um uh um that I had in the
original bill so that's why um this was
the competitive Grant was an interim
step to getting hopefully to something
more
comprehensive the competitive Grant had
a
appropriation in here of I think 1 a.
half million uh for 24 and 2 and a. half
million for 25 something along those
lines where um the original grant
program would have been considerably
higher than that
so what what was the what did the Esser
Grant look
like
so so it it would would be in the
ballpark of about a a million doll type
type Grant not A10 million type
well 51 schools are 51
districts and when when we when we do
grants at the school level uh I forget
how many schools Manchester
has 40
something does that mean
some some get it
some
okay okay okay
um well I I mean I I I guess I'm I I
would put it out there for consideration
as to whether or not this it would be an
opportunity here to use this bill as a
vehicle uh even in an off-budget year to
to extend a a to replace the the Esser
Grant which I which has completed
correct um with a with with state grants
in with a state Grant in in that sort of
you know $1 to2 million
uh thing this could go to finance and uh
and then go to um joint fiscal for uh
you know final appropriation if you want
to take a look at um the bottom of page
four um Roman five y um is the
appropriated amount um for the next
couple of fiscal years um and the um
competitive Grant would be up to
$75,000 per
school5 million in the aggregate yeah
yeah so if you know if we wanted to bump
up that total I have no problem with
that um but um you know with the
original Bill scenario we were thinking
more in the um uh $10 million and up in
terms of the cost per
year would it be would it be more
effective for for the Department to be
able to direct the grant where it's
where where
where where you've done data collection
and and know that schools are not doing
it or would it be better to do this as a
competitive Grant I'm not sure it really
matters it would be about how they would
fill out the grant so you would rate it
right they would have we would look at
criteria whether it was evidence-based
so that's what we did in the literacy
Grant they had to State how they found
that it was evidence-based which is on
various websites um that rate programs
what works Clearing House evidence for
Essa they also had to write how they
were going to help their staff um get
trained in how to use use the program
right so that that was the second piece
and then what was their data to show why
they chose that PR program right looking
at that data again so it really would
depend yeah yeah no I I I appreciate
that I also appreciate the fact that
that that you know filling out Grant
applications requires a that's a
commitment in and of itself it too so so
rather than rather than putting up
barriers for schools to receive the um
the the development funds that they
would need to to um uh to train their
their professional faculty in this this
direction maybe that it's something that
the department could uh could could
direct
um if I could I I just mention in that
regard I I wouldn't want us to see us
get into a
scenario um which we had with the
differentiated aid for um third grade
reading where we just gave out a flat
amount of money for each student who was
um below proficiency um in that regard
with uh with no accountability or or
Direction um coming from the district on
how those funds um would be used or were
being
used
um
about $75,000 can I ask meliss question
U Melissa the other day I believe you
were there with the
provos okay okay well when I when I was
meeting after the trustee meeting I
think it was last week on on Friday
afternoon the commissioner was there oh
yes meeting with the Provost of Keane
and uh Plymouth and
UNH um they indicated that they in their
Departments of Education are moving
forward forward with instruction in this
area of literacy for all their new
teachers coming out of those
institutions so I'm I'm reassured that
that you we have some cooperation from
our postsecondary institutions in the
state
here um however you know I'm I'm I just
and and where I'm concerned is uh
several of Words which you know really
uh to me are kind of you
know
ambiguous but I I I'm concerned that the
the program that we have here is another
one of those Grant programs like we saw
with a math learning communities where
we had 36 high schools very involved
starting to show great growth and then
Finance stopped the funding of that
program and the Community College had to
pull out um and and uh that hurt in the
high school level that was a very
similar type program where we saw real
deficiencies in math understandings and
skilled knowledge um so um if we don't
have really concurrence here in terms of
wanting to make this a long-term effort
we're going to have another statute on
the books which is not going to be
funded and with that it's going to be
very difficult for districts to comply
with some of the terminology we have
within here that they can go ahead and
be using this as a method of instruction
but when we were use words like in
intensive and and the general education
I take that to be exactly what you said
that's the classroom teacher MH and
that's going to be just another ask of
the classroom teacher which they should
be doing this they should be working
with remedial kids and and but they they
may have other methodologies going on
and and then it comes Arts local control
issue on curriculum and instruction so I
think there are some issues here which
we have to uh recognize I do support I
do support what we're doing here uh but
I think there's going to be some red
flag to go up as we go along the path
here to get this thing in place and
working I don't know how to address
those without having the cash to make it
work and yeah Melissa white would have
to speak on the financing part of it um
because I oversee the professional
development the reach out to the schools
and the support and that front Melissa
would control the finances do you have
any more uh title 2 monies that have not
been used I believe so I work closely
with the title 2 department but I again
I don't have the finance I know that
they've been supporting training um and
they brought in the Brett Conway um data
driven decision-making three-day
conference but again I don't see the
finance side of of the department I'm
more of the boots on the ground
supporting the teachers
okay if if the subcommittee feels that
um the 1.5 million in the next two years
um should be bumped up and let Finance
take a look at it you know I have no
problem in submitting um the amendment
with uh increased dollar numbers
there um so I so Glenn I I was only
suggesting that in um you know by
essentially replacing the bill to to
provide an ex uh uh uh you know
financing extension to the to the
Department's grant program I you know I
would I would take out I I would really
take out everything else and um and and
let House Bill
377 have some time on the on the
screening side and and you know extend
some support through the department to
schools that um that you know need the
um need additional you know uh training
in professional development in this area
that that's all I was suggesting thank
you
um maybe in time we have remaining
touch
what let 377 do its work since it just
went into effect this is the dyslexia
screening just when to affect the indic
P um and use this as a vehicle as a
potential vehicle to to um to support
the department
in its in its um in a in a grant
program to support professional
development in this area and take out
all the prescriptive um stuff that that
you know that I think probably does need
more work and
and sort of reads against you know other
places in statute like you know 193e
that says local districts are
responsible for determining
instruction I I think we would be
missing a huge opportunity um half of
our students are not proficient in
reading and just to prolong that um
penalty or that uh chain on our students
in terms of learning how to read I think
would be a huge huge mistake um 377
um was targeted to dyslexia and Related
Disorders this is targeted to a much
broader uh audience of students
um um and
addresses um the uh teacher prep
programs we do take a look and require
an addition uh a report each year from
the Department as to what's going on in
those teacher prep programs because um
uh you know we've seen it from studies
that National studies that have been
done with three of our universities
getting D or Fs in terms of their move
in this direction and I've heard it from
um a reading specialist whose daughter
um is attending one of those colleges
and they're trying to teach
both the evidence-based science of
reading and the three queing method and
um her daughter is just confused about
what what's going on um so we we address
that um we try and make sure that
there's more parental involvement
Community involvement U parental
involvement is key um in um making this
work I think so to just um have a bill
um related to funding and to delay um
the rest of it I think would be a huge
mistake on on our
part um let me just touch on a few few
more things um I just mentioned a couple
um in terms of the uh annual reports
based on um uh the teacher prep programs
and Survey of the those programs um I've
talked with uh uh Dr applebe about that
um and they're um uh on board with that
um annual reports from um the department
as to progress of coming back to um our
uh committees in the house and the
Senate um is all included in this um as
well as um what I mentioned in terms of
the certification renewal process um and
making sure that those teachers um had
been through uh the knowledge of reading
assessment so that they are up to speed
and uh on the last page that requirement
is only in place for certain teachers
and not everybody would have to go
through this assessment um and it was
pointed out to me that um even with the
initial
certification um I don't think that
special education teachers um go through
the knowledge of reading assessment um
and we include that in here um because I
think that's uh very important because
um as part of this um if after a certain
period of time uh the deficiencies
um are not being um uh there is no
improvement let's say um there would be
a call for referral to special education
so special education teachers also have
to be on board with this I
believe
um so any you know we're a few minutes
past our time encroaching on the next uh
uh Bill and subcommittee but are there
any further um comments I'm sure we'll
have uh uh I I will be putting this in
for drafting um so if there's anything
else please let me know but um you know
we will I'm sure we'll have a further
discussion on the 13th about
it yes I would love it thank you I was
just waiting for you to be
done um you know I mean I've been in the
field long enough I'm licensed as a k
to8 Elementary ed teacher I've taught
reading um to keep up those reading
skills over the last 40 years just
because you need to um I'm also licensed
as an English for speakers of other
languages and have to teach them L you
know L uh language skills and reading as
well um and testing them and been
through this evidence-based reading um
quite a long time
ago and um it seems like historically
every time there's um a nape score or a
state score that comes out it creates a
rise in people like nobody's been doing
anything and now we need to put the fire
out and nap scores are only for those
participating districts right it's not
everybody it's only grades four through
eight and traditionally we don't do as
well in the nape scores a better valid
and reliable measure is our state
assessment which measures reading and um
and math and that's what from my
experience school teams will use to look
for um instructional areas of weakness
that they need to beef up on and
specifically which kids need something
different so it's not new and of course
after
coid kids were responsible to learn
their basic reading skills at
home and unless they've got somebody
there to teach them they're going to
come back to school and be a year or two
behind which obviously has happened I'm
hoping that within five years maybe
sooner that will balance out again so we
get back on a
Continuum um but we have to think of
that part we also have to think about if
kids come to kindergarten without all
their pre pre-reading skills or language
development which many in poverty don't
have those skills they can swear at you
they know how to manage
money but you know what they might not
be able to tell the difference between
Bic sounds or not um so we have to think
that that's a big piece on reading
success so then when they get to
kindergarten you get the gamut and the
range of academic abilities on where
kids are in reading and so that's when
the three- tier model of instruction
became more formalized I mean when I
started out at College we were doing uh
ability grouping and leveled reading
groups right and then we called it uh
response to intervention which was more
defined um you know and it's been a some
districts then over time called it the
multi-tiered systems of support so that
you do Universal instruction all kids
get the same instruction and then
through assessments screenings then you
start divvying out who's mastered that
and who has not um and then you have a
second tier of intervention it might be
a small group within the classroom or it
might be a title one tutor or it might
be a reading specialist and if the
students who are screened after those
skills are presented again then they may
have to go in a the a tier three which
is an individual instruction which might
require them to have a totally different
approach to reading uh Wilson
foundations reading recovery slingerland
was you had to write in the air cuz kids
didn't hear sounds you talk about 3
queing I honestly until I came to this
committee had never heard that term but
in learning what it is it has to be a
tool in the toolbox if you have a
student with frequent ear infections who
can not hear sounds and can't put those
blend those sounds together they must
learn through site so you have to have
I'm not saying it it's there's no one
method that's going to work for every
student but somehow you have to teach
them those five components in whatever
way or learning style they have so
teachers have to be very um they have to
have a toolbox they have to have a
variety of materials there's no one
basil program's going to work for all
kids but you have to start with
something for all kids um I I was glad
to hear the child study team or the data
data flowchart so we've been abiding by
this and the child study team questions
on when to progress from tier one to
tier two to tier three it's pretty
scripted and then um the flowchart for
it really is dated 2006 and comes out of
the Rochester school district I mean the
stuff is just not
new
um the other thing I wonder is um so
there's a lot of components to get kids
to learn how to read and you can't kids
are not clones they aren't all going to
hit that proficiency Mark at the same
time and unfortunately some kids can
only learn up to fourth grade level some
kids can only read up to sixth grade
level or eighth grade level but you have
to give them your best
shot um
I think that this reminds me of what's
in a local curriculum guide for teachers
to follow step by step within a district
I mean it's a method of
instruction you want a certain
curriculum to meet that instruction and
that's local control unless we are all
reading
Specialists I don't think we should be
handing this down to the teachers fact
if I was a teacher I'd say this is
pretty insulting how dare they I've been
using a screening for 10 years
um we progress monitor one of those
tools that was used widely in New
Hampshire was nwaa and then they came
out with uh progress monitoring progress
monitoring is a very common
term amongst Elementary School
teachers um the other piece on part
five um on page three where there's
mention of um the special ed process
process I would caution about that
because every single district is
required to have a procedures and
process manual for children with
disabilities and it's mered from the
state so within those manuals
locally there is process and procedure
on what has to be followed and it comes
down there are specific questions that
have to be asked you know I mean I was
talking to a parent yesterday I saidwell
kids needs are not being met well how
are they not being
met well they're not identifying kids
the way we want them to be well there
has to be a discrepancy between the
achievement testing and the cognitive
testing and if those are within a
certain point span then it creates the
potential for a disability and then the
team has to decide does the child need a
different program as a result of that or
can their needs be met and so it's very
very prescriptive and the teachers are
very trust me they go to lots of Ip and
special ed meetings um and they're very
well vered in
it um so handing this
down you really I mean I feel it insults
the teachers I
mean it's they know what they're doing
they do it every single day we're not
doing it every day and we're not meeting
with kids every day but teachers
are um and I
guess I'd want to know I mean I know
what's going on in the North Country
schools but what's going on in your
district schools representative do you
know what Effingham and Crescent Park
and do you know what those schools are
doing Carpenter schools do you know what
they're doing for reading no no um
because I think especially in the wilbo
area my my colleagues there um have
always had the financial resources to be
able to stay up with the most Uh current
training and whatnot and really my
experience with the Department of Ed
they've always had strong people in the
field that have been very helpful and
resourceful
um but we're talking about something
that's been out there for a long time um
and I think that you need to trust the
system and my other problem with this
that I mentioned this the last time as a
legislative body we should be concerned
about all kids learning to read and this
does not address all
kids and who's going to submit yet
another report to the Department of Ed
it doesn't really makes sense nobody's
got time to submit their beginning
middle and end of year data it's already
in their software so somebody wants it
here it
is um so you don't want to add more jobs
to the district it's really it's really
government overreach in my opinion um
because there are so many factors that
go into teaching kids to
read um so I I would definitely like to
see the department
continuing to provide those trainings I
mean as I said before I was trained in
letters uh 10 years
ago um so it's not new I mean it reminds
me of the
competencies I mean Vision 2.0 for New
Hampshire was developed under the
directorship of commissioner Barry when
all school districts had to develop
their own competencies in all the main
subjects that's not new either um so I
think we need to let the people in the
department who are The Specialist to
support our school districts to ensure
that all
kids no matter how they're educated or
where they're educated get get the skill
set that we want out of a productive
student can I just you any questions
could I ask one yeah um how do you think
this does not address all
kids because it talks about um wait a
minute looking at the wrong one is it is
it designed for local school districts
and charted Public Schools
yes well there are kids out there in
Learning Centers and nonsectarian
schools aren't there or am I thinking
that all kids are here right I'm I was
trying to address public education in
this only public education yes okay well
that's what I say we're we're missing
some kids here
just trying to be
Equitable I've had no problems you know
addressing public school kids in this
without getting into non-public school
kids I have one more comment myself um I
administered the nape for the state of
Vermont prior to getting on board and
coming in the legislature here and the
results you see in the nape I wouldn't
give a whole lot of uh consideration
I saw students in there taking this test
just because they had to be there the
test wasn't written in a fashion that
you were going to get anything out of
the child yeah uh learning style
teaching style wasn't even thought of
there uh so we we see those types of
scores so I I throw the naatee right out
the window I do the same thing with our
Statewide assessment in terms of it's
not a diagnostic test no and it doesn't
do it it shows perhaps in terms of what
what we Norm reference and what we're
assessing it shows growth from one year
to another in that particular area but
it really doesn't glean from or for the
teacher where I need to aim some of my
instruction in order to see uh a better
understanding of the part of the skills
and knowledge on on the part of the kid
so I I I I I think that there's a lot
that's going on within School right now
that you don't see any statistical data
on because they're doing it individually
within schools I was teaching a lot of
this stuff dealing with phonemics and
and phonemes and and fluency and
vocabulary and comprehension when I was
a teacher in grade four in the
1970s and and and I remember what was
going on with Paul leather and Jenny
Barry uh on this as well I I I support
the idea here that we have to get our
reading literacy I don't buy into the
the the concept that 42% of our kids in
the state are not proficient in Reading
I don't buy into that I don't think the
assessment really assesses properly
um so there's there's a lot more to this
I think we always should be striving to
improve our reading to improve our
mathematics uh yes we have to do that
and uh uh but you know I I I I like a
lot of the stuff in here don't
misunderstand me but I just don't know
if we're if it's the right way to do it
I don't
know I got a lot more thought to give to
this you know part of the um data
flowchart is also using faded measures
you're not going to get a number you're
not going to get a statistic from it but
if you do a running record what we call
a running record on a student you're
going to get some fluency yeah and
you're going to compare it or um if
you're drilling on uh site words you're
not going to necessarily score that
you're going to see how many site words
do they know and then send the list home
that they don't know or need to practice
kids need to practice reading they can't
just have a reading instructional lesson
without all the other parts you know as
you know and you have to practice
anything that you're going to get good
at and unfortunately some kids only get
it in one place um and I was concerned
also you had mentioned about a
progressive spelling
inventory
um that's pretty curriculum
driven I don't know what what that is
spelling
inventory is it doing
spelling I don't know I mean spelling is
taught in conjunction with cursive in
conjunction with you know so do they
keyboarding in first grade to do now
they got to give up keyboarding right
because there's no extra time and you
got to add cursive but yeah this is like
a local Pro this this is all good stuff
this all should be done I just
question where is it not being done
because to me it should be pretty
rare Rosen
lakus I think in your last comment you
just answered my question
is you said it was
insulting and I'm trying to understand
is it insulting because they should
already be doing it and a lot of places
are I know you ran I mean the thing is
you ran your schools very well I know
you
did
and not all school systems are run as
well as you ran yours right right and
and so if they're already doing this
can't they just say cool we're already
doing this we're all set but there are
school systems that aren't doing this
and I think that's the need for this as
you said everybody should be doing this
yeah and that's the whole point
everybody should be doing this but not
our school districts are run as well as
you ran
yours understood thank
you further we'll move on to the next uh
next subcommittee well thank you very
much
um take five minutes
y the next uh subcommittee is uh on uh
House Bill 623 establishing a teacher
candidate loan forgiveness
program right so we'll take five yeah
okay thank
you
62 I'm I'm picking up Mel
so he have an amendment I'm going to go
upstairs it's 623 right 623 which is
echoing 618 617 it is complete mirror 27
mirror of 217 yeah yeah so we should be
able to go through this sub pretty get
get back on right yeah does well yeah
I'd like to see how he's written it
whether because with are we dealing with
Rule and and and critical shortage
communities or are we dealing with
specific topics like mathematics science
special education shortages so can you
pull up two pull up Senate 217 yeah and
then I'll go get this
one
last night
really uh okay I think um we'll start
with the next subcommittee um little
different cast of characters but
primarily the same
um and this is House Bill 623
establishing a teacher candidate loan
forgiveness
program
um and this bill has taken um several uh
turns and with
Amendment um and we just got a uh new
Amendment uh this morning uh based on
discussions last week
um do do you know if there uh copies
available out in the um audience I I put
a oh there's some okay great yeah um
this is uh Amendment uh
2375 H and um representative luno since
um represent Miler is here do you want
to just
uh generally tell us about the amendment
so so thanks and I'll I'll you know re
really this is not something that I've
been directly working on I think
representative may may be able to to uh
shed more light on it since uh since uh
I think this um is part of the U the um
uh work product that came out of the um
the teacher shortage and retention um
working group um study committee study
commission it was I think it's been a
multi multi-year effort yes yeah so um
so my understanding is uh is the Miler
Amendment uh 237
uh
mirrors we're just double-checking this
mirrors a Senate Bill uh that has uh has
traction over on the other side of the
wall Senate Bill
217 and uh uh but but Rick I defer to
you to you know okay I I'd be I pleased
to do that uh the education uh shortage
committee has been addressing this issue
and why we have shortages of of of
teachers in certain critical shortage
areas and we know those critical
shortage areas we've mentioned them over
and over and over science mathematics
special education uh to some degree
Career Technical education but we won't
go there with that right now um the and
we're looking at the bill that you have
before you the amendment
623 mirrors
sb217 which is pleasantly retained in
the Senate under uh Senator Ward's
committee but where does this come from
it comes from the state of Idaho which
just put this almost identical
legislation into law and what it does it
tries to uh maintain or attract teachers
in the shortage areas um and I don't
know if this bill specifically
identifies what the shortage areas are
but we know we are short teachers in
some areas within the state when it
comes to lure and certification we've
been told by um Mr applebe Steve that we
have licensed more teachers in this
state than we have in previous years
however then you have to dig down into
the weeds and find out yeah how many of
those licenses are for people living in
Nevada who have New Hampshire uh
certification they're just renewing them
and how many people are on retirement
now that are renewing them just to keep
something in the fire in terms of that's
my insurance policy if I have to get
back to work
so but we do know we have shortage areas
and those I've mentioned uh Idaho has
done this by uh saying to a uh a new
teacher that comes in or a person that's
there in a critical shortage area or in
a rural area that can't attract or loses
uh qualified teachers to other districts
which pay more that in the first year
you get X number dollars second third
fourth and by the if you stay there the
four years then you C captured $122,000
to help pay off your Grant which has
been very successful out in Idaho very
success so successful in other states in
the country so we on the shortage
committee the other day when we're
trying to wrap up we're not totally
wrapped up yet because there's another
issue which we have to resolve but we
have wrapped up in agreement that this
process is important and that we should
from a policy perspective move this
forward the only issue out there still
is how much is it going to cost and so
that's a finance issue which is going to
have to be resolved by division two or
by the Senate side in in uh uh Senator
Gray's committee there so but I
encourage us to take a good look at this
and and see if it parallels uh what we
feel we have to do in terms of keeping
and acquiring the teachers we need in
the state there's some areas we just
cannot find the number of teachers we
need and then when it comes to
maintaining them and keeping them uh
that with their extreme debt that
they're carrying out from you know the
the four-year degree that they possess
there's no way they can stay in the
teaching business they got to get back
out and seek something where maybe with
some Corporation or business that's
going to pay them almost another 30% on
top of what they're getting paid right
now so that's it in a nutshell uh it
echoes Idaho this bill almost verbatim e
Echoes that state and it echoes 217
which is in the Senate and we asked
representative Miler modify HB
623 W language that's in
217 and I haven't taken the time to read
through this yet I just got it I've just
been doing s yeah and that's probably
what we ought to do uh the only area
that I because I know this is going to
cost some dollars but I don't know how
much that's something we're going to
have to get from the
Department um an analysis in that regard
but I is it going to be for any teacher
that comes in from any institution be it
in New Hampshire or be it Outsider state
is it going to be for any area like an
elementary teacher going to have the
same benefits from this program or are
we going to key it in initially with the
shortage areas
this is direct to Rural and right this
is going deeper I was saying it's for
science mathematics special education
Etc right uh yes yeah I just wondered
what that rural School District list
would look like if it's fewer than 20y
old students per square mile within an
area that's one criteria right and the
other one is is
shortage in a certain area like critical
shortage list is that what the inent the
the other states are doing it they're
they're defining rule differently in
each state and I think that this would
be an area that we should have defined
here we've had uh definitions for
geographically isolated schools in the
state before in legislation that has not
passed but this is an area I agree we
need to look at this particular area and
see is this going to capture the areas
we need to
capture yes and I I mean I just see it
as a great marketing tool for those
areas that can't find people I mean AOL
School K to8 has 13 kids who the heck
wants to go teach in arrol New Hampshire
when there's no housing anyway in the
distan is good fishing well yes but I I
just use that as an example but I'd be
curious to see what that list of rural
school districts would look like to make
sure that we're
capturing you know those areas because
the there are areas like that I'm sure
in other parts of the
state right in terms of the the dollars
I think that there is an appropriation
on page three so um there is an
appropriation anyway for this um you how
many
teachers at um what cost um you know
would be uh um compensated under this
appropriation um however it does the
last line uh was added that the governor
would draw a warrant article um to fill
out that uh money from the
treasury
um uh so yeah and one of my questions
also was related um to the uh specific
areas of teaching um that have been
discussed um special education was was
mentioned um but I also uh a couple of
us were talking with the U special
education Advocate um this
weekend um and uh based on her work so
far um she identified not only special
ed teachers but also occupational
therapists speech language Pathologists
uh reading specialists
as areas where there are uh teacher
shortages um that are impacting special
education and the actual services that
are in IEPs for students that cannot be
provided because of um those shortages
yeah I was talking about the 13 IEP
categories with underneath the umbrella
of Special Ed soid I would capture all
those categories of the IEPs so that
includes occupational therapy those that
are working with uh TBI those uh all
that autism specialist spe Pathologists
right so so so just to be just to be
clear though um uh Senate Bill 217 and
House Bill 623 is directed to Rural and
underserved um areas and it does not um
make any there there's no further
criteria in terms of what what teaching
areas are are you know where the
incentive would apply so it to all
teaching areas for these for these uh um
Rural and
underserved uh districts so you know
possibly another bill could you know
with another appropriation open it up to
all districts and and and specific uh
teaching areas but I don't think that's
this bill okay um you know it's my
understanding of it again I I did not
serve um on the uh the this multi-year
Commission um and and this is work
product that came from that so I I'm we
we talked about this and as you note on
the amendment that Mel has just given us
uh on line two a page two it talks about
economic disadvantage of the school
based on eligibility for funds pursuant
two Title One Part a um we're trying to
be able to capture places like
Manchester right uh which are are having
a difficult time you
know getting these people and
maintaining these keeping them so it's
not just Rule and so we we put in this
and of course that yeah and this is
where the department has some has some
leeway to to extend that um this program
to areas that it identifies under Roman
2 on the first
page with exactly what you just
said you're right so I I think we've
been looking at the definition section
which talks about Rural and underserved
but actually there's the third area as
you point out
yep
yeah
yes go ahead thank you so I think you
just answered what my question was but I
just want to make sure I'm understanding
the way it's stated here
correctly so number and number two at
the top of page
two qualifying schools would either be
rural isolation as previously defined on
page one or economic disadvantage based
on title one they would not have to be
both is that the correct interpretation
I believe so one or the other y so it
fixes the issue of the Claremont and
Newports and manchesters that are not
rural thank you um my I guess based on
your question would um that also cover
the
underserved areas which are in the
definitions but are
not under Roman
2 should there be a a b and c under
Roman
2 represent tell I
concur representative Paul you got a
question thank you thank you um I'm so
concerned about that teacher who's
teaching let's I'm going to sell these
Town out so maybe they don't fit on the
list but not but let's say someone's
teaching in gton and they've been there
for two years it's a new teacher they've
been there for two years and they're
Rift they're an excellent teacher and
they end up going to Berlin if Berlin's
on the list or Errol or wherever through
no fault of their own
they've been kicked out of a an
underserved District because it's any
subject so now they get a job in cber or
whatever another underserved District
it's like I said they have no control
over their performance other than they
were an excellent teacher but they were
Rift um so they don't they're done they
can't get any more money and that
doesn't seem fair to me it seems
like if they are serving those districts
so when we go to page two um line 20
lines 24 and
25 the educator remains employed at the
same school or the same school district
they're out and that doesn't seem very
fair to
me represent
Damon so could we propose in response to
representative Hall's valid
concern that instead of it reading on
line 2425 of page
two uh remains employed at the same
school or by the same school district to
change that to remains employed at any
qualifying
District so they did that example they
went somewhere else that's still
qualified um one one of the the goals
was to try to keep these people in that
rural School
District they may jump they may jump as
represent Hall saying from let's say a
havil where I am to
Hanover and receive a huge jump in their
salary now course then they wouldn't
qualify because they'd be out because
it's not an
underserved
District yeah I but see it's also
hurting though the the the rural
District which is going to see that jump
occur and once again you don't have
continuity programming you lose that
teacher which has been very effective
now gone and it's going to impact on
kids can I follow up on it sure but
through no fault of their own they went
there hoping to stay there five years to
be able to take advantage of this
they're going to stay there five years
and they've been rifted that is they
have no control over that
none
so you know how can you be guaranteed if
you're good you're going to be allowed
to stay there for 5
years I don't
know and and why would they be leaving
if they were if there were reduction in
force often times the language is Last
Man in first man out mind you they have
five years to decide you know the
superintendent has five years to decide
but I think that there are certainly
teachers that would fall into this at
some point in time they get riffed and
they want to want to teach and an they
like being in the North country or
wherever that is and they go to another
underserved District like say through no
fault of their own so so they want to
stay there for five years Mel if I could
if I could respond to that
um down on Roman three at the top of
page two there's this this you know this
program laid out in statute gets defined
in rules adopted by the commission
pursuant to 541a so that's where the the
you know where where what you're talking
about could be placed in rules it you
know the you know the the statute
doesn't necessarily statute frames it up
but the rules specify what would what
would happen so I I would I would
suggest that this frames it up pretty
well and some of these Edge conditions
that you're talking about are absolutely
valid but that could be done during the
rule making
process
um you know it may be it may be too
difficult to consider every Edge every
corner
case in
statute and um and the other thing is I
I think we do have another retained bill
with respect to the um what the um
higher education commission can
do
right yeah oh yeah so this is putting a
couple of a couple of um
of requirements on the higher education
commission to Define eligible education
expenses and to adopt
rules and I think the higher education
commission can do both of those
things but they would be the ones
administering this um this incentive
Grant it says they shall adopt
rules right yeah
clearly further yes represent
D um just clarifying from what
representative luno just said because we
in the corner here have the same
question so can the
rules
development say something that is
actually different from the language of
the
law because it's kind of specific in 242
five yeah I mean there there has to be a
statutory underpinning for the for the
rules
um being employed at the same school or
by the same school district
um I mean we I mean we could get a I
mean we could ask you know an OLS
attorney about about you know that um
you know if wanted to get some
clarification on it but uh
yeah you just pointed out something to
me something that I had marked on a
previous
version
um terms of the
rules you should say state
board
why wouldn't it be the
commission you know and I'm not sure how
we word it in other I I
think yeah I think it's
yeah yes
one more thank you no different okay so
I'm just noting that in this amendment
compared to the previous one on page one
line
16 um it no longer includes Federal
Parent loans the other Amendment did
include them as is that in order to
align it with what the Senate
has
so it's a little less
qualified does anyone know um if there
has been any uh action over in the
Senate on their routine no they they
haven't done anything yet anything okay
and once again this legislation is just
an echo of what happened out west and
they have been uh you know doing it for
some time now effectively um to get back
to the area that you had uh Muriel um on
on those lines on the on the reverse
side um employed at the same school or
by the same school district um you could
capture it by saying taking line latter
part of line 23 on page one remains
employed in an eligible Public School
District or at an eligible Charter
Public School um you just take it from
that same language which is line 23 and
24 on the first page and replace where
it says the same school same district
all that stuff
on so we could we could get around that
you could be in an eligible
school which would have to meet those
guidelines already established within
the bill
yep be a simple
fix so there could be two or three um
fixes in an amendment that I see um that
that you just mentioned um on the top of
page two maybe make it a b and c to
include the
underserved um and on line
33 um who's adopting the rules and the
fourth change we we'd have to assess the
definition as represent cadens what what
is a rural district is is it 20 enrolled
students per square mile or or is there
some other appropriate way
yeah we we do that we do that but is
that good for our state how many how
many schools are captured by that we
need more information on that agree
right Brin would no I don't think it
would
mil it's geographically isolated though
from the rest of the state yeah and and
then you've also got the HHS list too
yes that's right that's next line down
yeah
um okayy I think there's three or four
things then that uh we can take a look
at um the rule definition um including
to the other three um areas that we just
just mentioned um for the
13th uh representative beler thank you
Mr chair and I know I it sounds like you
guys have done quite a bit of work on
this and Advance things uh a fair bit
forward um but I wanted to just step
back and point out a couple things that
that seem like they could be issues to
me um the first the first thing i' would
like to point out is if if retention
issues are are primarily or majorly
related to benefits packages being
inadequate it doesn't make a ton of
sense to me why we are looking to go
straight to student loan forgiveness
rather than simply increasing pay
packages where teachers on an individual
level would have the ability to direct
those funds where they feel most
appropriate at any given time we all
know that housing there's a housing
crisis housing is very expensive they
could then choose to use those funds to
buy a home if that's where we're heading
if we need to increase if we need to
increase the benefits package that seems
more appropriate to me I would also
point out that this appears to single
out only Federal loans as being eligible
for forgiveness I I'm not sure why we
would want to um exclude uh private loan
providers from this particular
program um I would point out that
looking to specifically subsid or rather
pay for student loans does effectively
have the Dual track of not only
increasing benefit packages but it also
effectively subsidizes Advanced degree
programs and from where I stand I don't
like the idea of of doing that and I
think it also fails to address a primary
cause of retention problems in schools
which is teachers being regularly abused
by students where there is not a lot of
Avenue under our current guidelines to
be able to take corrective actions um I
I hear about that quite a
bit good points is to yeah um the
situation representative C Ken um yeah I
agree I mean teachers are having a
difficult time because of the abuse by
students and verbal abuse by parents but
I I believe that it
can't we can't put money into the
salaries to increase them because that's
a negotiated item and they're bound to a
collective bargaining
agreement and I don't know if there are
districts that have actually loan
forgiveness in their collective
bargaining agreement maybe Muriel
knows but that's why I think it's
isolated from that because it may not be
common yes thank you I'm just thinking
so if it's in even if it's in a
collective bargaining
bargaining contract um if the town
chooses not to fund that contract let's
say you you negotiate a settlement and
the town doesn't fund
it right so then you don't have the
money H I'm thinking out loud here
um yeah yeah that's all I was thinking
like sometimes the money is not there
even
though they fund a number of teachers
and then the and the town votes to cut
the budget by a million dollars now
you're going to get rid of teachers that
they thought they were going to
have any further I think well the the
the teacher shortage committee is coming
up with 10 separate recommendations this
is one of those
recommendations so in terms of some of
what you represent mentioned represent
beler those like the the teacher that's
being assaulted by students in the
classroom or pushed downstairs breaking
their hip like my daughter had happened
to her when she was teaching at the
middle school in St John's spray
Vermont those we we are addressing those
types of issues through the shortage
committee recommendations this one right
here where is trying to really narrow
down this one area how we might retain
them with this extra support to help pay
off their debt and that was echoed to
was over and over and over again
teachers are coming with huge debt and
that's one of the reasons why they don't
even want to get in the teaching
profession right now because who's going
to be able to pay off a debt of you know
$440,000 when your salaries to or
getting you're getting paid $38,000 to
start out with it's just you're in that
hole and then capture the housing cost
which you've alluded to and everything
else associated with they just can't
afford it and we recognize it you know
when you come right down to it this this
$122,000 is when it compared to some of
those debts that we heard is a fraction
however it
helps and um where we've seen it
actually proven elsewhere than the the
committee absolutely felt that this is a
a a a track we should try to explore and
take is one one of the possible answers
that we have to come up with just one
aspect and Brian you were there
um and and
uh I know you gave a lot of input and
you were the one that really identify
for us that this did come from Idaho or
this has has been put into effect Mr
chair could could Brian come forward
please
sure from your perspective in in the uh
uh of all the teachers in the field that
you work with Mr Hawkins um how how is
this bill
perceived and and can you give us any
kind of a background in why this tact
was taken working with Mr applebe over
to uh doe sure for the record Brian
Hawkins and Y New Hampshire um I think
this is uh perceived as you know
reducing barriers to to entering the
profession and we know that the pipeline
of uh people coming into the profession
has taken um a hit it was uh referenced
earlier uh about
licenses uh the just take a look at the
newspaper and the job advertisements and
uh it is a a major struggle um there and
uh so this is this is uh not the uh
Panacea but it is an important component
I think to um in in in a multifaceted
way to to address the
issue um one uh in uh with respect to
Idaho this uh has been a very success
they've had a
successful
uh time with this um to begin with
there's a lot there are some
similarities there with New Hampshire as
well um and um this was some of what we
heard in the shortage committee where
you had districts that need people to uh
to move to rural areas in order to uh
fill some of these positions and so this
can be helpful one one additional um
question that was raised I think I can
answer is um in addition to the uh
definition on Rural uh the Senate Bill
adds the rural public health network uh
so that borrows from the state loan
repayment program that is already in
place by the Department of Health and
Human Services that program uh is for uh
healthcare workers and um so that is a
already uh comes directly from their uh
the definition that they use for Rural
um and you can even look at a map online
to see exactly where that is um
um using their
criteria so something already being some
something already in place and has been
a very successful program in healthc
care for the for the Department um they
were able to uh uh give that program an
infusion of um Federal money um but
uh and and and and and they have had u a
great deal of success since they've been
able to um put that additional funding
in I hope that
helps any further questions U yes
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for being here to provide this uh
information I just wanted to ask based
on what I one of the things I had said
assuming that the the issues around the
contract could be worked out would the
uh would the Nea support a move if we
were to take this bill and amend it to
say instead of providing direct student
loan forgiveness we just take that money
and put it directly in the
paychecks well I
think I think the best way to do that is
I mean schools are run by people and uh
you can't educate kids without uh the uh
staff and the professionals there and I
think that goes back to the school
funding issue overall where you know the
degree I mean because many of the
districts I think we're talking about
that would fall into some of this are uh
both Rural and underserved and um their
ability to deliver higher salaries we
were talking about Newport versus
Hanover is so much a function of um the
economics and the way we fund schools so
I think
that the being able to deliver some of
the targeted funding that the
legislature has considered is helpful um
and I think I would definitely support
continuing to do that because I think we
we should do more in that area and I
think when you look at the ways in which
school districts are uh deploying those
funds it's to help keep
people uh and and and attract
people and we haven't even gotten into
par professionals and support staff
which is a whole another issue but um we
could spend a lot you know a whole
another hour on that or more one of the
things M thank you Mr chair one of the
things that the shortage committee did
discuss if the payment went to paying
off the loan then the young teacher or
the teacher that's coming in and
collecting this uh this uh support would
then have money in their paycheck
to put more towards housing because they
wouldn't be having to pay off such a
high debt in the course the interest and
all that so it was to be
consistent um the the process would be
similar for everybody receiving these
types of support because we'd be working
with the higher education institution
are paying off debt uh and it's through
the federal government and all that so
we were trying to keep it accountable to
trying to wipe out that debt which we've
heard so much for that's why a lot of
folks aren't getting education right now
they're coming out buried in this stuff
and they got to we got to attract them
in and if we can help lessen that debt
we may attract
them um one question um I wanted to go
back to if I could um back to the uh
teaching areas that were mentioned
before um if this is not the right
vehicle for that because it's uh
targeted to Rural and served areas is
there another vehicle that we see coming
down the
pike um maybe identified by the shortage
committee that would be um the proper
vehicle for addressing
that thank
you or is that something
that we need to address at this point uh
in addition to the rural areas
I I think that that's a a question for
maybe Steve applebe who's very familiar
with those areas which are shortage
where they are in the state and what are
the subject areas the shortage is is in
uh we we have discussed it and and uh
certainly we we'd like to be able to
attract teachers to these rural areas or
to the underserved areas or those which
don't have the
economics to support
um and
attract and I'd like to see it for all
categories in those schools however if
if we're trying to be cautious here to
initially get something in place
sometimes it's wiser to go with you know
we know that we have absolutely a high
preponderance of shortage Area Teachers
a math science special in these rurual
and economically depressed areas we do
have a shortage there we have in the in
the state too seeing that even though
you may be in a district where you're
paying you know maybe
$70,000 that's not going to attract the
technology person that's going to get $1
110 $120,000 by going off and working
for BP so uh it's is a hard one to
tackle and I I think the committee right
now is trying to look at this
incrementally and you know even I
suggest at the very beginning do we have
to even go in down down further and
identify those subject areas where
they're teaching in um that might be a
nightmare to try to administer that
program it might be easier just to say
you're in a shortage area you do
qualify okay no further comments I think
we've got um a little bit of language
work to do and um maybe some research on
Rural schools um for the
13th um so uh with that we'll uh end
this subcommittee and um turn it over to
Chairman lad for the uh 11 o'clock let's
take let's take a f minute
break
okay I think we ought to go ahead and
start um we have four bills
left on the docket for
today the first of which we're going to
in support uh represent Damon who has to
got it get out of here who's not in her
seat
yet moving fast okay and she has an
amendment for 505 uh that's uh relative
Comprehensive Mental
Health uh education in
schools and wellness education in
schools so um why don't you uh explain
what you have as an amendment here
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
um this is from discussion at the last
two work sessions I believe and it is
very simple to explain it simply removes
the word
comprehensive which was in the bill uh
um in the title of it under an act and
in the text of it as well so literally
it just takes out that word
comprehensive before mental health
education um and makes
it let's say more
generalized okay given that we were not
in agreement on what comprehensive would
be okay um further discussion from the
committee on that
one further discussion for folks here
represent
dry so I guess my question
is I looked at what was already going on
in the schools and in the the um
curriculum and to me it was everything
that I would suspect I would want to see
in a mental health curriculum and I'm
thinking mental health while a problem
is is the the the headline problem right
now and I don't like to make
lists um because you always leave
something out and you have to keep
changing it um it is to my satisfaction
that what I would expect a mental health
curriculum to cover is already being
covered so I'm I'm I appreciate the the
fact of of trying to make this
fit but it it goes against the way I
like to do
legislation further discussion represent
P Pell I just want to say that I agree
100% with representative dry thank you
Margaret further discussion yes
represent
Amon I'd just like to respond to those
thoughtful
remarks the fact that it may be
happening adequately in some school
districts at this time does not diminish
the need for us to specify that should
be happening in all school districts
ongoing if it's not in statute when the
306 rules are revised What's Happening
Now can go away and that's not good for
kids represent cordelli thank you I
think that I to my satisfaction anyway
um it's been indicated that uh mental
health will remain in the
306 uh rules
um and um I I think that current
language talks about health education
certainly um for me that means both
physical and and mental health so I'm
I'm uh fine with uh the current um
language in
law okay we do know that it's going to
remain in the 306 we have statutory
language
193e which which stipulates that the
areas which are identified in the
section one of that part of the statute
I'm referencing those substantive
criteria areas of
study those cannot be changed or
Modified by
rule unless approved by the general
court and so we've been told that this
is one of those substantive areas health
and wellness that cannot be changed in
rule so what is in rule will remain in
rule so
but I I want to also read a a little bit
that came out of hb2 that's a bill that
was passed and went into law 2 um
approved in 2023 June
20th it says findings Children's Mental
Health the general court recognizes that
the ongoing mental health substance
substance misuse and Child Protection
crisis have taken a significant toll on
New Hampshire's children families and
taxpayers
and New Hampshire schools are challenged
daily to support the behavioral needs of
students while promoting academic
achievement for all students and it goes
on and talks about mental health and
wellness um so it's been placed in hb2
and signed into
law but we have no reference to it
underneath studies and so my my concern
is do we put that in underneath studies
or not um I I handed out and I've looked
at it and I've done some twisting around
on this um however I feel that when
we're talking about health and wellness
under studies we are talking about
mental health it's a part of our our
health program we've identified it both
what I just read right here but also in
our uh uh Frameworks for health and and
we know it's in in
rule by placing it in studies we would
even more strongly guarantee that it
remains part of Health and
Wellness I also felt like well you know
we could also put the word nutrition in
there too seeing that our our areas of
306 and and uh Frameworks address the
issue of nutrition as part of curriculum
that's also referenced to later in stat
too so I I I I actually think that we we
won't have to do that but I I just like
to throw it out there and say why then
are we not
wanting to put this in
statute under studies is there a reason
for it when we're already doing
it and we all have it in hb2 represent
dry I think Health has a number of
facets that aren't listed there um
emotional health spiritual
health things that maybe haven't hit the
headlines yet that we're g to have is a
crisis coming down the road I just think
that if you put it Broad in the statute
and uh make it specific in the rules and
regulations that's that's the way to
go yes represent
Damon I wish
that the general understanding of the
term
Health included mental health as a basic
component mental health physical health
all under the umbrella of
Health but that is not the language of
our society today in hardly any context
that I've been involved in I think it's
really quite quite
important that we incorporate
that simple two-word phrase mental
health as something that we want our
students to be educated
about further discussion on this
one yes represent cordelli thank you I
um I pick up the uh newspaper or um look
at articles on uh online and uh uh
there's not many days that go by I don't
see something about mental health in
schools um so I don't think that
awareness um is the issue and just um
adding it to what is already in statute
um will make any
difference further discuss represent
belshire thank you Mr chair and I mean I
I gave a significant presentation and I
I won't rehash all the details of that
here right now we can we can go back and
look at that but I I will once again say
that
we are looking to solve a problem here
in mental health that is very
clearly something that we are also
causing at the same time at least in
significant part through the way that
we're conducting ourselves in our
schools and the way that we go about
doing things this was clear in testimony
we've heard before we see the evidence
for this everywhere further we know from
the the mere statements of the
professional organizations involved the
mental health field by and large is a
captured
institution it is placing things like
activism and social justice above its
ethical duties and that is what we're
looking to be instituting here I I think
that's off
topic I I I object to that discussion as
part of this going on in
schools okay let's uh just jump past
yeah one of the things we want to be I
I'll see that we have this is a
committee the whole we're all here um on
all these bills which we're going to
have this year coming at it's all 100
plus bills and the 20 that we've
retained we are going to have to utilize
our time uh effectively and efficiently
and we if we're going to say things we
better make sure that we have the facts
and the signs behind us and that we have
uh uh something to offer that's going to
be relative to this bill now yes that
that was relative to the bill what was
just mentioned by represent elure he
indicated that you know he's feeling
that within the schools that uh you know
we're bringing some of this on ourselves
and yeah we're we're we're doing that to
an area of
nutrition we're putting a Coke machine
out in every corner of the of our lives
and we're doing this and that and
everything so
um it's the classroom the teachers which
are having to deal with us on a daily
basis
and I don't know I have I've not been in
a classroom where I have never seen need
for a good teacher to be able to have a
grasp on how to correct
Behavior mental
Wellness of students there uh you're
going to have to do it if if you if you
don't have them on board you're not
going to be teaching anything
academically so it's an it's important
topic and um and so is physical activity
you know we've also been told you know
take the kids out and run around the
soccer field a couple times before you
get into the academics and they'll calm
down and they'll probably learn better
um I used to do that as a fourth grade
teacher and the kids really did achieve
well after they've been out there and
got themselves a little bit tired and
the same thing occurs with a a good meal
if you they're not if they're hungry
they're not going to learn and that's
all part of Health I had it as a young
kid in school that was part of the
instruction and and and behavior was
part of that instruction um
unfortunately somebody I didn't listen
to but um so be it so um let's let's go
on here and any further discussion on
505 yes represent repent
no um in the health education curriculum
guidelines from 2003 the definition of
health education is a planned sequential
cas through 12 program that addresses
the physical mental emotional and social
dimensions of Health has that my first
question is has that definition changed
in the last 20 years and um if that
definition stays I would um
recommend um that this whole section
needs to be Consolidated because it has
begun to become too specific in terms of
what we are requesting the teachers
teach their children the children and
they are already overburdened with the
with the issues that we continue to lay
on them as
legislators okay I'm going to take an
opportunity to finish reading what I
what's in hb2 it goes on and says in
response to the New Hampshire Department
of Education uh C's office of Social and
emotional Wellness has supported
approximately 37 New Hampshire school
districts in implementing an
evidence-based prevention framework to
support behavioral health and wellness
of all students called multi-tiered
system Sy of support for Behavioral
Health and Wellness or mtssb mtssb is a
key component of the system of care
established under RSA
135f so this is something that's being
pushed by our own Department of
Education to recognizing that we've got
to do something uh regarding the
behaviors that staff members are
experiencing in these
schools and there's a system of tiers
now of course we you all know the one
two and three tiers and what three
stands for that's you know where you're
really in need of some medical type
support um but it's the teacher on tier
one that's involved with this and you've
got to be able recognize that um we
can't close our eyes to it we can't bury
our head in the
sand represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I agree with
your
remarks I'd like to ask the folks
who do not support this to be specific
please about what in this you don't
consider important for students to
learn what is it that you want to not be
there because it all looks important to
me
Prof I don't think we're saying that
this isn't important for the students to
to learn I think we're saying they're
learning it already and we don't see the
reason for it to be added to
statute further discussion
representative cordelli yeah I just go
back to um some comments I made at the
uh last meeting on this and that um it's
nice to put into uh law that you know
this should be taught and that should be
taught but um especially with this area
uh unless we address the root causes of
some of the mental health problems in
the schools then what are we really
accomplishing um I'm thinking of
bullying for instance um gotten two
calls um in the past um two weeks about
uh cases uh going to uh School boards
manifest education hardship um related
to uh to bullying um uh you
there are um a number of causes that we
can
address and should
address other than just putting um
another word in in statute we should
that's what we should be looking
at further discussion represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair um
with with respect to what representative
cordelli uh just talked about you know
and
bullying it would it would it would
appear to me that that codifying mental
health education would uh would help to
relieve and reduce the uh the instances
of of of bullying in in any type of um
uh environment and um and you know the
way the way the section in study reads
now I think is improved by adding the
words mental health um
education uh to um to assure that um
that that continues to be uh be
something that's uh that's taught in
schools and not something that that
disappears and then we see the the
effects of a lack of mental health
education um manifest in other areas
like what we're what representative
cordelli uh was talking about um that'd
be my comment on on it on the on the the
merits of of the of house bu 505 and and
the amendment that representative Damon
puts forward but uh but my other comment
is that following our last work
session and I don't remember when that
was I've got it somewhere around here um
I uh think so many yeah yeah might uh on
October 18th and um and you know I I
thought we had sort of agreed that
dropping the word comprehensive the uh
the Bill's Prime sponsor was here and
and she said yeah I'll support that cuz
I think this moves It Forward I thought
we were um in general agreement maybe
not 20 to nothing but uh that uh that
dropping the word comprehensive was um
was was going to be how we were going to
move this forward so I'm not quite sure
what changed between now and then but
representative Damon clearly took some
instructions or based on what she
thought was instructions from the
committee to prepare this amendment
um you know based on that work from two
weeks
ago we have another bill that's uh going
to be decided it's not on the docket for
today but it's uh
151 DL title that is relative to mental
health
education on is putting mental health
into
adequacy and that's coming to us from
the Senate with bipartisan Senate
support
I have a difficult time putting that
into adequacy seeing health and wellness
is already in adequacy however I see
this as the more appropriate Avenue to
take of putting it underneath studies as
a component of this subject health and
wellness and I I just don't understand
you know why
um why the would it be S better we put
down Behavioral
Health uh
it yeah there there's representative
leus I was in Texas the 18th so I wasn't
here for that meeting but I'm wondering
this paper that you handed out that's
labeled
[Music]
um as that it's um as introduced us and
then there's all these changes who did
all these changes because I do like a
lot of what was done with this including
fixing the
part um where it says these content
areas of health education support the
safety academic success and wellbeing of
students and relate to adding that in
there I think make that make a whole lot
more sense getting rid of comprehensive
was excellent nutrition I think is
important in there
um where did this come from I wrote that
the other night and the bottom part
education Sports safety academic success
well-being of students and relate to
that phraseology came from Texas and I
think what we are doing we're starting
to write down all these areas of Health
and Wellness physiology hygiene Health
interpersonal relationships those are
already in law the only thing we don't
have down there is nutrition which is
extremely part you know I think we all
had you know a a classro in in in
elementary school at least I did on you
know on nutrition it was part of Health
the you know and and and mental health
is also part of this that's why I
thought well this all belonged in one
area this area studies needs a real good
cleanup and it's it supports the Health
and Wellness which is inadequacy but it
then further defines it here in studies
we did that with personal finance
literacy as well represent leus I think
you're right on the same page I am in
terms of seeing this is a good way of
stating what health and wellness is and
what are the components of it um by
doing this we have them all there now
because we have interpersonal
relationships already in
there so representative
belard
thank you Mr chair there was a question
put to the committee about what
specifically they might object to as far
as being taught under the rubric of this
bill so I would like to put out there
one thing that falls under this rubric a
statement recently put out by the
president of the American Psychological
Association in regards to what's
happened recently in the Middle East let
go of the fear let go of the lies let go
of the control issues let go of the
manipulation let go of the selfishness
let go of that which has been stolen let
go of the denial let go of the tendency
to dehumanize let go of the the greed
decolonize that is something that I
would object to being taught that seems
to come under this rubric and you
wouldn't have to look further than
documents put out by the APA to find
this same sort of thing within their
broad purview of what they now consider
to be mental health
education further discussion represent
dry thank
you I think actually that paragraph two
is is an example of why I don't like
lists is because the first sentence it's
health and education health education
and wellness then it talks about a
little broader categories like
physiology hygiene health and
interpersonal relationship and physical
education and wellness great if it
stopped there that would be good but
look at the two things after that you
have to do Abus child you have to
reference a definition in a different
thing that's that's a subject that's
come up it's been in the headlines we
added it to the statute HIV what the
headlines for a long time now it's
specifically in there uh this is the the
minutia that I think does not belong in
a general category like
studies further discussion represent
Amon I I hope I misunderstood what
representative dry just said because of
it if I didn't
misunderstand it sounds like you
consider child abuse in hi
to be minutia and I'm sure that's can't
be
right represent Dr yes represent Dr No
it's not but I believe that it's it's a
category that's already covered in the
things above that um and it's just a
part of we don't want to leave anything
out so we have to keep making a list
that's longer and longer and longer and
they're all important
thank further discussion
Rick Rick yes
yes are you offering um your your markup
as a I I just brought that for
discussion purposes uh I'm just looking
up uh RSC 126k colon 8 because that is
re referenced under the substant
criteria under well health and wellness
uh and I was just looking at see and
that speaks to uh possession let's see
eight colon8
if if you were to look
at um underneath the adequacy public
education portion 193e colon
2A the substant education contentment of
an adequate education under Roman one it
lists one through 11 subject type areas
if you look at seven which is health
health and wellness education comma
include a policy for violations of RSA
126k
81a and if you look at that that goes
back to I believe the use of
tobacco and and so and that was a huge
issue in our society and Still Remains
such but at that point in time the
legislator must have felt that that's
important enough to put it underneath
the adequate
education and supporting it with the
funding for it which that the tobacco
revenues coming in the state are used in
that direction but you know we just
talked about you know the the list of
things which go on here at the end U
like which they
referenced U HIV they mentioned you know
sexual transmitted diseases Etc like
that's been in law ever since I've been
here so I don't know how that got there
uh it's certainly an area where we're
putting a lot into that particular
section of law and somewhere along the
way this is the area that needs clean up
and it needs probably a separate area
within something there uh because if
we're talking up top and we've been
drifting towards trying to Define what
these studies are and by doing so that's
why the support for adding in several of
the other topics which we have listed
under 306 and we have listed that then
we'd have it
done and then we're going to have to
start figuring out you know how to clean
up the rest of that statutory area the
whole thing needs fixing so so Rick
would would it be fair to say then that
that under the definition of an adequate
education
1932a where we've
got number seven health and wellness
education including a policy for
violations and I believe that's the
smoking the use of tobacco um that that
that's in the definition of adequate
education in what what you and hope have
done here under studies
provides additional clarification and
definition as to what what what um
health and wellness
education should comprise that's exactly
what we started doing when we added
personal finance literacy in there under
under under adequacy under adequacy but
then also went to studies to explain how
that may occur you might embed it in a
subject area like economics or you may
have it a separate course that's what
we're trying to do with studies now is
try to further Define how some of that
works using that to tease it out as ex
rather than loading it all up
inadequacy okay good thank you
yeah okay so I don't think there's going
to be a whole lot more discussion on
this particular area right now we ought
to jump to the next bill and we probably
get on that one
and and uh then we'll have a couple
which will take a short break for lunch
and then come back and get the other
other two hammered in uh we should be
out here by I would think today by
1:30 the next bill is
147 let's see 147
147 this is the bill dealing with
the advisory Council there for special
education and the membership
and I've seen so many amendments to that
right now I don't know where I am on
that I thought represent B bony she's
not here today because of illness but
going to work on that a little bit uh
for
us I believe representative B bonies is
the one that came from representative
Tanner okay they worked on
together
okay
okay do you do you have the number of
that just yes um is
2363 yes 2363 H yes did you get a copy
of that that was handed
out
no
Lind are there more copies of that
Linda's Amendment yeah
2363 there are some up there Jan's going
to bring them around
and I just want to say that this
amendment was done in conjunction with
representative katab who had a lot of
input the new chair of the um Sac that
was elected at the last meeting um many
parents who called and many of the other
stakeholders who are on this so this was
really a collaborative effort of many
people to put this membership list
together did you work with represent
Tanner in this represent Cornell
somewhat we had we had a zoom and we and
we did talk about it also with
representative cascaden um
representative Tanner and representative
bbon did the bulk of
the work okay we we've we've had this
discussion then we know that there have
to be a majority of parents on there
with disabilities or children with
disabilities and in looking at other
states uh they've been able to manage
that with fewer people uh on this
Council you're recommending now there be
21 individuals with disabilities app
parents of children with disabilities
appointed by the
governor and then all the others how
many total people are now on this
Council as proposed in this amendment
I'm I'm I'm total I'm actually not sure
but a number of the people that are on
it are in federal regulations that have
to be on it um so that's why some of
them are on it and I believe part of the
problem in the past few years is with
the number of parents or individuals
with disabilities not being on it was
they hadn't been appointed by the
governor so there were a number of
openings for a couple of years that
never got appointed
um I I know it's a lot of people
but yes I I counted I counted 40
40 is that a workable
group I I don't think this number is any
more or less than what it's always been
and up until the past few years I think
they all found it workable and and think
they accomplished
stuff why is it that other
states have half this number of people
on there they don't have all these other
categories on there as well so if you
have lesser of those categories you're
not going to have as many parents
because you won't you still you will
have a
majority but it it seems to me that
every time
we add something down below you got to
add another parent
on it's
like when's where is it going to
stop I'm I'm gonna just invite one
person up here uh Lisa B Bodwin has been
past president of the the the
organization we're talking about here
and Lisa do you have any comments as a
past president of that parent advisory
Council uh there must be some history or
some insights you might
have yes you do thank you for the record
my name is Lisa Bodwin I served as chair
of the New Hampshire State advisory
committee on the education of students
with disabilities for four years and I
was on the committee for
six um I do believe that when you add
specific categories specific delineated
categories at the bottom um then you do
have to add numbers of parents I think
that I would I would want a chance to
reflect and get back on you but um a a
committee of 40 is a bit unmanageable
and I can share with you some of my
experiences um not only related to the
the the size of the committee but other
issues um there was a period of time for
over 2 years when the governor did not
either appoint or
reappoint um new members or existing
members on the sac committee most of
those were parent Representatives which
made doing business very very difficult
um so we definitely want parents to
engage uh it's critical I am a parent of
a young man with Down Syndrome so I
understand the importance of providing
um guidance and recommendations to the
commissioner on the endet needs of
students with disabilities um as someone
who has been through the rigorous
process of of um dealing with an IEP
team um I would say that I would like to
discuss for a moment um the importance
of having both the disability rights
Center and the parent information center
included on this list regardless of the
number of parent
Representatives that you fundamentally
end up with as a number making sure that
parents of students with disabilities or
people with disabilities remain in the
majority regardless of who else you cut
off I just wanted to provide some
commentary on why it's so important to
retain the DRC and pick is it okay if I
use those acronyms sure and Sack okay
great so pick and the disabil ility
rights Center are and were during my
time a critically important part of the
duties of New Hampshire Sac each of
these organizations hears from parents
of students with disabilities from
across our beautiful Granite
State every day every week they hear
from parents whether it's Coos County or
marac County these organizations share
with sack the experience of students
with disabilities from a wide range of
disabili
and age groups which means that in those
moments when
parents don't get their reappointment or
their appointment or they have a sick
child or they have to parent because the
sack meets from 4:30 to
7: that by State Statute there is still
representation by the seated members
from pack and DRC of students with
disabilities because each of those
organizations their missions are in in
fact to serve the disability community
and those professionals have knowledge
of
Ida individuals with disabilities
Education Act the 504 plans all of the
state law and regulation that we add on
to the floor which is
Ida so whether we are considering um the
the in critical need of having a broad
representation of of what students with
disabilities experience as as it relates
to their unmet needs or whether it's
just simply getting guidance during a
Sac Committee hearing most parents don't
take a deep dive into Ida
504s um and state regs I mean they're
broadly Familiar of course because
parents of students with disabilities
have to be but if we are there to
provide guidance and issue
recommendations on the UNM needs of
students to the commissioner we cannot
get bogged down during a Committee
hearing because we don't happen to have
perfectly
memorized timelines on IEP processes or
federal ieda
statutes um I'm almost done with my
formal
um so they provide appropriate relevant
guidance leaving members unog down by
those by that knowledge
base
um and in those moments when parents
can't be present they definitely act as
a voice um I cannot stress that enough
um they don't take up seats from parents
but when parents can't be there it
ensures um
representation and I also um have heard
that um this uh work group has not heard
much from parents who support the uh
presence of pick and DRC on the sack um
it is very difficult um to reach parents
um neither Pick Nor the DRC engage in
lobbying um they don't teach parents to
Lobby that's not their function um pick
is very very strong in particular on not
encouraging parents um to support their
work um and this is not an easy time of
year to provide information on on the
idea that pick and DRC might be removed
from sack so if you're not hearing from
parents um they're parenting and this is
not an issue um that that either Pi or
DRC can can put out it's it's not their
it's it's not part of their mandates so
um I can try to reach out and make sure
that you hear from dozens of parents who
would support this but I'll I hope that
my um previous leadership at Sac has
helped to illuminate why it's so
important to have those Representatives
on the committee thank you very much
represent
dry thank you in the interest of maybe
reducing the amount of people on there
are there any of those positions that
could be non- voting members that would
show up at the table and be able to put
give input but not necessarily have to
be a voting
member uh that's an excellent question
and and in order for me to answer that
for you I would have to think about it
and get back to this work group on which
um which of the
representatives um would be best served
just simply providing information and
being non voting in terms of putting
them in technical advisor roles to the
committee that's a great
idea would that be appropriate for I get
you in second art would that be a a a
good way of uh having the representative
from the disability rights Center or the
parent information center there as
technical support in your presentation
to us just now you talked about they
give us support right and
information I in my opinion I believe
that because of the direct the amount of
direct contact that they have with
families the kinds of training advice
and legal support that each of these uh
pick doesn't provide legal I'm I'm
meshing together for the purposes of
expediency you know they they do legal
support they provide problem solving for
IEP team meetings that get stuck they
they pick Teach as parents how to deal
um with being a good partner in the IEP
process um they have such a vast direct
experience with what students with
disabilities face I think it is
appropriate given their direct contact
with families and students that they
should have a voting um a voting seat
thank you very represent Ellison thank
you thank you for being here this is a
question I guess to Patty and to Rick I
mean we're what's what's rolling around
in my mind here is what requirement are
there for having people from
institutions on this group now Patty
you're real clear that somebody's gone
through this and you and Linda and it
requires 20 given this list Rick is
saying there's states that have must
have much less than 20 because the total
group is smaller so if you had 10 you'd
only have to have 11 parents it's not
unclear to me what the federal
requirements are then for seats on this
particular okay represent Celli would
you please read off the ones which are
required by ceral
law
okay um starting from the top parents of
children with disabilities individuals
with disabilities
teachers
sorry could you do it from the amendment
he's doing I'm doing it from the federal
law we got to go really slow okay um I I
can I can have copies of made this made
for everybody well some of us have
received that before yeah in in our
hearings here she's getting a copies
okay because it is pretty specific and
we have other groups and that are on
there that are been put on there by us
the legislature in previous
years so are there any uh further
questions for Elise at this this time I
I do have one one or two recommendations
from
um representative Tanner's amendment I
would I would recommend
that the representative from DHHS be a
technical adviser um in the six years
that I was on sack despite showing up at
the Brown building and sending multiple
emails to the commissioner requesting
that they um ensure that a
representative show up um HHS has not um
sent a representative to sack in it in
at least the last seven years that I am
aware of um and I would
um
also um
recommend the um the
H
are
and and also H those would be technical
I would recommend right off the bat that
they be technical non- voting
members go if if I could just interject
um in terms of all are um one of the
federal requirements is a representative
from the State Child Welfare agency
responsible for foster care
okay and so clarification on that if
it's a federal requirement do they have
to be a voting member I I am unaware of
that if you'd like I can get back to the
work group on
that
yeah
y
okay in your experience uh as as chair
of that
organization uh what about item d one
represented vocational Community or
business
organization um that has always been a
tricky spot to fill and in my time my
six years there was not much
participation from that individual when
they were
present um my understanding of the
history and of of sack is that
this these roles were expanded to try to
incorporate as um nuanced and detailed
approach to being able to examine the
unmet needs of students with
disabilities and in in seeking detailed
representation for individuals with
disabilities up to the age of 21 and now
of course in New Hampshire it's 22 that
is where all of this um specificity has
arisen
from it's it's amazing that when I read
the other states they say ages 3 through
26 and then they also have uh statutory
language where the parent or the person
supposed to be attending can't come
today because I have a parent teacher
conference or some other rationale they
can designate a
substitute that's that is a that is a
wonderful and most the states I looked
at the other evening when I was trying
to figure this stuff out have that
ability for to have a substitute acting
on your behalf that is a voting person
at the time that they're there yes
additionally um there are parents in the
North Country I I know three parents
from the North Country who would have
loved to have served on the New
Hampshire sack but you can only um you
have you must be in person to vote um
however I would like to inform this work
group that the quality
Council of the developmental disability
system now has permission for um Zoom
participation and the ability to vote if
they're virtual in part because that is
an accommodation for people with
disabilities who who have transportation
challenges and so a real barrier that
this work group might want to consider
is is mandating that you must be in
person in conquered when you are a
parent of a kiddo with a disability
between 4:30 and 7 and that you cannot
um have a have your vote count unless
you're in person that really Pro that's
a barrier
for families with disabilities so um if
you
could uh address that and resolve that
barrier um we would struggle less to get
um moms and dads involved that's a good
point represent Cornell and I could be
making this up but I I thought that it
got changed and as long as there was a
quorum you could vote over as long as
there's a quorum in person in person
okay thank
you okay any
other thank you very
much Al righty uh we have that that
sheet now which identifies everything in
federal law that we have to
have
uh ages birth through
26 so now they got it down to Birth has
hasn't been
PR
there are some states that have that and
that was mentioned when we had wasn't a
doe that mentioned that to us at the
last meeting you could count if you're
there as a person from doe but if you
also have a child that's you could be
also counted as a parent I I think the
parents didn't like that that's right
yeah yeah so the parents are going to
be a
majority it's pretty hard though to say
that I'm not a
parent and my child's in a wheelchair
and I don't
understand I think that's why some
states have gone the other
way represent cordelli yeah I just I
think that we've heard several hours on
on this this one bill um about
membership of a council um and my
suggestion is that you know on the 13th
we look at the Amendments that we have
before us and
vote represent
leas yes I'm I'm trying to understand
could you explain why two individuals
with
disabilities were taken
out it would be
k
because it's the same as 21 individuals
with disabilities or parents of children
with disabilities appointed by the
governor okay thank you
yeah is there any more disc uh just
quickly I you know I ran the list here
of required Representatives I come up
with 14 and this gets into wordsmithing
because one says a representative from
and then there are a number that say
Representatives which means I guess that
means two but counting all those it came
at least under the federal requirements
for a I will use agency people that's
not correct but that's what I'm picking
up 14 required people to be on this
thing and then the question is is that
is that the minimum is that what's
required uh and we're at 20 now based on
the based on what we've got anything in
between you know drops that total number
down and I'm I'm not really interested
in uh sort of lowering the membership
number of people if it works it works it
can work at 44 it can work at 40 but if
one of the issues is it's too large we
can get it to 25 or
26 maybe the chances are works better so
I just think we really need to figure
out what's required under the federal
law and then what have we added in in
legislation or everything for a while
here to get us up to to to
20 I I think that's good point you know
what's required there we got that now
let's go on and add to it but keeping in
mind there's going to have to be a
majority of parents yeah and so be very
careful that we don't get duplication in
an administ rators you know are we going
to have a the administrator of the
Special Education Association or you
know the representative which is an
administrator are we going to have other
types of Administrators on there or is
one
enough I don't know I sat on it for a
while myself and there are so many
people in the
room uh it it was you know tough it was
tough It's hard to get business done
when you have numbers like this
yeah so what are we going to do here
because we are running out of time yeah
so you know a lot of times there's a lot
of people in this room too but there's
20 people around the table and we get
advice and input and technical support
from people who are not necessarily
members of the House Education committee
is that a way that this um committee
could could operate uh with regards to
for instance the the the the DHHS
staff um you know somebody
from uh business organization conserved
with transition Services things like
that could could they be non could could
they help out the committee um as being
non-members of the committee but but
being very important guests to be in the
meetings did I mean do these do these
committee meetings have hearings and
hear from
non-members of each yeah each meeting
has an agenda um certainly can have
invited guests we have invited guests
all the time so uh you know I don't see
any problem with invited guests to a
meeting but would that be a a way of you
know would that be a a
helpful disposition to get down to what
art was sort of
suggested I think you need one of those
members which were talking you know I
look at the advisory Council for CTE we
have a department person on board that
sets the agendas does the scheduling
does the
communicating really keeps us on course
uh that's Jeff
beard um there needs to be such a person
for this so that you're going to have
your meetings over at Granite State in
the conference room and you're agendas
you're going to walk in the agendas are
already completed you the chair works
with that person setting up the agenda
um I think that will work uh so the next
step for us would be to okay we know we
have the required by fed law here or or
the the regulation here then then let's
try and find out who else was really
needed there as a voting member and what
kind what of all these who could be a
technical support person I I think we
have to be very careful with the
technical support and taking over CU I
think one of the complaints from the
parents was feeling intimidated and
feeling um that they weren't in control
of the meetings that the that the
officials or the people
representing they that they were
intimidated by them and didn't feel that
they had as much say so I think the
technical support and getting all the
help and having it be set up and and you
know help from the Department of Ed but
I I think the like the chair that was
elected needs to be the one that's in
charge I I as I recall the technical
support was more in terms of um since we
have zoom access um for these meetings
to have uh make sure that the uh
internet availability and zoom access is
available on a consistent
basis that should be something we can
work out fairly easily another technical
question on the amendment um on on
uh make sure I find it on page
two Roman 6 does does that so down at
the bottom line 22 is that addressing
what representative Myer was suggesting
that would that um that that this
committee needs some
additional uh support from the
Department uh maybe even the department
needing some funding to make sure that
that support happens is that sufficient
to um to address the the resource
concern
yeah well on a lot of our committees
which we've had before like uh if on
some of the trustees we've always had
non- voting member it says it um in the
uh committee for Teacher shortage uh we
had uh Steve applebe technical support
that was written in the law underneath
the list of members although he wasn't a
voting member he was there for technical
support well in in this case I'm not
talking about technical support um from
for information but technical support
for the logistics and um preparation of
the of the meeting because I uh I think
that was a concern that had come out
that sometimes the internet worked or
sometimes something wouldn't uh you know
wouldn't be working properly but does
this direct the department to to address
those concerns to make it easier for the
um for the chair yeah to focus on the
meeting and not focus on the making sure
that the desks are lined up well I would
think that this would do it okay yeah I
I I think that as long as it's technical
support that's well
um either defined or the intent is clear
um rather than having someone from the
Department taking minutes and things
like that um you know that would be my
concern
okay yeah
represent
as to that I think it's it's hard enough
to get people to go but I've been told
like the superintendent of the um County
Corrections if they're not voting it's
hours of their time night they're not
going to go that's right
yeah how important is it for those that
have been on this to be there as a
representative do they look to the
legislature for guidance or
support speaking for myself in my time I
don't know if they look to the
legislators for uh support or guidance
um in some cases that might not be a
good idea um but uh um certainly when
they're talking about um uh proposed
rules or proposed educa uh proposed
legislation um one of their duties is to
provide uh feedback to the
commissioner uh so having someone who
can uh discuss what uh legislation is
pending um is I I think a good
thing so that they have the ability to
give feedback to the
commissioner but do we need as many I
mean do we need a senator do we need two
Representatives yeah do two
representatives and take out the senator
that's one that we
could does it
say um
I think in the past we did have Senators
um um attending I I remember Senator
Reagan to being attend uh in attendance
quite often at meetings um and I believe
currently Senator
Ward yes Senator Khan as well right yeah
and wouldn't you need one representative
and one Senator just so you have the
information coming from and going to the
two separate bodies I because you may
have a bill that's
being that's coming from the Senate that
the House of Representatives don't know
about yet so rather than two
representatives in one Senator you can
have one representative in one Senator
it would cut down but you would still
have that information going back and
forth to each
body just a
thought okay let's quickly just take
well five more minutes at 12:30 we're
going to take a lunch break but um let's
walk through this thing skip over uh 2A
which is the number of parents we can
figure that out based upon the number of
others we can just give the majority do
we need on line 10 B two members of the
house can we strike that to
one yeah if we put in the Clause that um
Lisa kindly recommended permission to
have a sub
we'll have one rep and the rep if they
can't attend can make sure they have a
sub so everybody's in agreement that one
rep okay let's put a one there and get
on to the next one uh C uh two members
of the Senate one Senator is that good
yeah we already that
d uh one representative of vocational
Community they haven't been there
they've been not attending do we need it
scratch
it is that required
yeah yeah that's right that's what they
have so we that's
required okay next one e one State
education official from the Department
of Education appointed by the
commissioner of
education is that
required what is it
position talking about I I believe um in
the past it's U been the special
education director so if we have one
that's doing McKinny vinto on the
homeless which is later on is that the
same official they're from the
Department of
Education what is State education
official from the Department of
Education the Department of
Education this is where we're getting
theal it says
Representatives so it means more than
one I think
way but see number five requir in the
Federal Regulation there is also
captured on this on page two under
Q so that that person that comes from
doe could be the same
person so we leave q and we take out
e because the Federal Law requires mckin
vento so we have specify yeah let's just
take out
e or unless and and that might be the
technical support technical
person proba very helpful and tiido the
the the director in charge of
certification and lure is the one that
came on as technical support to the
commission on teacher shortage that
person can also be that person that
provides support but doesn't have to be
a voting
member where you on
that well I'm I'm I'm saying leave e
there but as a non- voting
member and would be the person who
provides that
support just like Jeff beard does for
the
CTE Council advisory Council these
meetings are public meetings right yeah
yeah so if they're non voting
members but if you want them there to do
that last partion here that was added on
the bottom here
online 22 or excuse me
this is a good way to get it just put
this person's technical
support to even non voting
member majority
being well a non- voting member doesn't
count still be
counted
many no no if they're not voting no they
wouldn't be they're not a voting member
they don't
count well you just put in parentheses
non- voting member that's what we used
to do with the
trustees non voting
member so if you label them Technic
technical support as opposed to members
then they don't count so just label them
technical
support
right but if it's not in statute they're
going to say I'm not coming now if it's
in statute they got to be
there as technical
support
some of the other
people show
up we could take it off if you had if
you had located on the next page at the
bottom there but uh by putting it here
you really identifying you're going to
have the person
present yes and that's it
says one state education official from
the Department of Education that would
be technical support or non voting
whatever you want to call
it let's put down right now technical
support by that one so the E person who
currently comes does not almost always
abstains so they're not really voting
anyways so the eers will just be
technical support right yeah okay let's
move on down
here um
f so that's the
new that's what everybody's most people
are saying we
need Okay so let's just keep
it uh next one G two teachers one of
whom shall be a special education
teacher appointed by the
governor I wonder if that should just be
one special ed teacher
they're all
plural that this Federal thing the
Preble says they'll be made up of
individuals involved in in order to
agree with that theyve made everything
plural all the way through I don't think
that requires multiple of all these
things I think it's just the
grammar
is any objection to making it one
teacher okay one
teacher yes one special ed
teacher it should be pral
yeah why do we have to even say you say
special education
teacher could be a retired
teacher A specialized
teacher okay so you want to have one
special education credential teacher I
think so yes credential
special okay going on down to
H this is where we discussed earlier
today the Health and Human Services they
never
show how many they want here in this
regulation one
one
[Music]
right
and that would
be
are we assuming that federal law when
they Define the membership that all of
those categories need to be voting
members or can we interpret that with
respect to the input we just got a bit
ago that the DHHS people don't come
anyway so they could be advised members
not voting
members I I think it's always been
interpreted they're voting
members I'm getting
creative nice try okay so are we keeping
H yes yeah
okay uh down to the disability rights
Center and the parent information
center doesn't require either of
those
so you want to keep those two areas
yeah everybody's yes on that even though
one has a lobbyist yes no no I'm
not I I heard the chair here today speak
of you know they shouldn't be a
lobbyist we had one sitting here at the
last meeting with the orange bayge on
regarding their status on they don't
train or otherwise encourage families to
participate uh in in Civic engagement so
that's in part
whyc because the DRC as an organization
doesn't do Outreach to
parents encouraging them to
have that didn't
yes perhaps be
the I don't think we should be not
having them because one is registered as
a lobbyist we get information and input
from lobbyists for other organizations
pretty much every day and we screen out
what we agree or disagree
with those folks have particular
expertise for this
population but they're lobbying for
students and families with disabilities
so I mean the re the thing that they're
lobbying for is the committee that
parent parents and families that the
committee is working to do things for so
they're
lobbying for what this
is they're not lobbying for for
themselves or and I think that's what
that um that's what they said was that
they they're they're lobbying for yeah
to making sure that their their
standards are being carried through in
in
legislation
represent
cascaden not that I want to go back to a
but my thinking is that it's critical to
have DRC and pick there as opposed to
senators and
representatives what
prohibits the parent chair for example
if the topic comes up of
legislation that one of those
organizations or the chair request a
member of the Senate education committee
to come participate in that discussion
at that meeting or a representative of
the education committee to go to that
meeting to have that discussion with
them without being named as members of
the
committee and keeping those two
organizations who are responsible for
parent
advocacy and for following the laws I I
I mean just just contact a member of the
representatives to have that discussion
I mean then you could eliminate
too so so you have these up there but
non voting
member
I has a
question Mr chair yeah I has a question
about let's when we're talking about
it's difficult to manage 40 people in a
committee or what is the difference
between voting and non- voting really
those people are all in the room and
then it comes time to vote so you vote
the difficulty is in the 40 people
before you vote
right that's right you can cut your
parent number
down see the more members you are if you
have 40 people there 21 of them are
going to have to be parents
yeah so if you can cut it down this non
voting you cut it down to 38 you can
probably cut down a little bit with the
parents
it's going to be tough to go from 40 to
20 right I mean what are you going to go
from 40 to
38 yeah thank you um so following
following up on that is does this do
this is supposed to do a report right at
the end there's supposed to be so the
report goes to this the
legislature
I don't know I think you're going to
have to have an elected PE person there
at the meetings whether they're voting
or not if we leave them in we've cut it
down to 16 which is 32 people total 33
people
total how many people think we should
take the representative and Senator out
of
it one two one two three four five six
seven
one two three four yeah eight but
the and that's how many here today 1 2 3
four five 6 7 8 11 12 13 oh there's a
majority people want to say Wipe Out
the personally I don't have any skin in
this game so that's
but C can we ask Lisa that's what I was
thinking did you find having
representative or Senator useful on the
committee I think it can be
useful and make anything can't move
anything forward um and and I I see it
equally from both sides um when a me
when members of the House and Senate are
present and they are present
consistently they also get to hear from
the parents that's what I was thinking
they get to hear about the issues and so
they are better informed about this
constituency which has a difficult time
gaining voice in the public Arena so I
see both you know and but the other side
of that is it can be part of the caucus
responsibility to say even though you're
not a voting member we we would like to
find someone who is going to
conscientiously attend these meetings
and be invested in this committee so
like I would have to think about this in
order to provide if you wanted my my
opinion but I just I can see it from
both sides
usually
assess accept
represent you you want to say something
Ben U I'm not sure if you know it's
quarter of one now I'm not sure if we're
going to reach a majority consensus um
by uh 2:00 um the way things are going
so can can
we anyone put in any amendments they
want and we'll we'll vote on them on in
13th well we we're all the way down to
the base here so we left one I and J
in taking k out
right um
L one administrator public
requ okay m one representative
institution of higher education that
prepares do they ever show up from the
postsecondary
yeah
so that's in law then okay let's move on
down
then one representative a private school
approved for special education is that
required no required one representative
Charter Public School appointed by the
governor that's required too
yes number
eight so so we we could one of those out
or or we could say one representative of
the private and Char of public
school or Andor Andor and just get one
of
them they're both they're both
required and why were they both
required
eight private schools and private
Charter Schools I mean this is going to
be the dry amendment that plural is on
everything here so we have one and or no
but it says but the Clause that refers
to the plural specifies two things this
one and this one and there's nobody that
right and and I would say with Charter
Schools one issue we have faced uh
multiple times the past few years is
who's providing the services to the
special needs child in the charter
school that's been a big issue they're
very I think
both but very important I
told oh one one individual representing
with children with disposed
homeschooled is that
required right they're not recquired so
do you want to take that
out okay take that one out O's
out
p okay Corrections and one
representative that's two right
there one is
required one represent from the
Department of Corrections
period right one from each I I I think
one from
each do in County Corrections do we have
children under the age of 18
yes sometimes and my superintendent said
he's very involved in it he likes going
to the meetings and they do and he wants
to work with them to get their education
so my my former superintendent um used
to go to the meetings because he likes
to go to
meetings mine said he would rather be
home with his family but when you're
dealing with these young kids which are
in the County correctional facilities
some of them have bys you have to chase
down the district that they're from so
the superintendant do get engaged or
they design number get
[Music]
engaged are you
volunteering so you know what are they
going to do to us if we have one
representative from the County
Correctional Facility well it doesn't
say County and
state and 11 says representatives from
the state Juvenile and adult corrections
agencies so it's Juvenile and adult that
we need not State and
County so Alicia which one were we going
to cut
out well they're both in there yeah we
you mean is depending upon State and
County um instead of putting State and
County why don't we just put it the way
it is it says state representatives from
the state Juvenile and adult corrections
agencies that's what that's what the
rule that's it's number
11 okay we can put number 11 in the way
it's in the regulation exactly the way
it is okay take
rig okay
Q state and local official as
responsible Point mckin
vento did we do that already up up
top I thought we
had yeah they're both they're both okay
this one's required yes okay so that
stays uh representative from the
Department of Health and Human Services
responsible for foster care required
that's
required okay if we tally up what we got
there for
the require for the ones we just went
through and agreed then we can figure
out the number of parents yeah and it's
less one
two
3 four 15 so we need 16
parents six seven
8 9 10 11 12
you could probably elim eliminate the
Senate and keep the
house the Senate is going to agree yeah
16 I still come up with
16 because some of those are
to because
um p is two one for one
one okay with the senator and the
representative 16 is that the total 16
yes
16 16 one of them has two different um
p p has two different ones one that's
adult and one that's youth okay
or Alicia's G do the amendment Alicia
you seem very really on top of this
right you want to do the amendment he
who proposes disposes is you're telling
sounds yeah it's okay I can do it thank
you thank you lunch anybody that wants
to give her any advice go do it uh we're
going to break for lunch and we'll come
back in a half
hour we do 354 next I think I've got
solution to that yeah okay
yeah we have on
the which is Apple be's shity Bond that
155 will wipe out real quick
yeah that's just knocking out the shy
Bond stuff and then we're good my
solution the
Char this is in the
um oh yes do you guys want to come to
lunch for
this
we have several bills still to do today
354 is one of them which deals with uh
Charter Public School uh building
a and the other one which is on the
docka Today is let's see 155
155 and that that one deals with the
higher
education and the indemnification for
private
postsecondary uh
organizations so let's get back to 354
here
um I've handed out a
Amendment which was
23088 which we had at the last uh
meeting there's also some a change which
I made on this I haven't gone gotten
another amendment so it's all for
discussion right now um and the changes
for the amendment I can go
through and explain them
um it it was
H and if you take the sheet that I
handed out I haven't change some of the
terminology at top it says changes only
on page one I'll show you where the
changes
are um you can see on page one where
paragraph 2B has been eliminated
that's a paragraph which was requiring a
charter school to put up a shy
bond in order to get and receive Charter
School building
Aid and the other change was on 2A just
above it where we have in the event of a
voluntary or involuntary
disillusion then on page two on line
eight and
nine uh there was no need to have that
sentence in there um and that was a
result of Correspondence I received from
the Department from uh Amy Clark who is
here
today and the other change on this
amendment is on the back page on page
six which is also underlined the
underlined areas that the changed
areas
um under the Charter Public School
establishment RSA 194b 32
Z it currently Says Z Provisions for
dissolution of the Charter Public School
including disposition of assets or
amendment of its program plan this adds
in a Charter Public School may not be
eligible for a State Building aid grant
until the State Board of Education has
approved the school's asset disposition
plan so what this basically the bill
that is is introduced by
representative M uh
Moody
um to allow charter schools to receive
School building Aid so that's what this
basically
does and the other change on the
backside which was discussed at the last
one deals with the records coming out of
a chartered public school which is going
through the disillusionment process it
says where those students records must
be maintained or sent to as a result of
the closure and we discussed that the
last meeting as well so it's open for a
discussion repr luno thanks very much Mr
chair and um and I know we had a little
bit of a discussion I think last
Thursday um you and I did with with
respect to to the concern around
um what happens to assets on dissolution
and um and well I think this is a a a
step forward with it particularly the
part in section
five
um I I'm I'm I'm thinking that that the
um that the language isn't going far
enough to lay
out what
um what would be required elements or
required um components of of that
dissolution
plan you know some some sort of
objective requirements rather than
leaving it up to sort of a subjective
assessment by the state
board that's sort of my my feeling on
what's in five
um would it could would it be
clarified to to do it here verse should
it be done through Ru making by the
department working with the State Board
as to other words put in a sentence you
know saying you know referencing the rul
making RSA
541a uh you know the rules to be
developed pursuant to
541a relative to the components or
requirements of the you know of this so
I I I don't think rule making would be
sufficient on I think we would need to
frame it up a little bit more okay uh
than that and it probably wouldn't
belong in um
uh actually is is Bol and3 is that the
section that defines what goes in the
charter
um document yes
okay and see you know I I think that if
we're getting into where I'm having a
hard time understanding where we're
going we're only talking about in this
whole
bill the state appropriated dollars for
building Aid and the if the receiving
Charter School receives six years worth
of building Aid and they're only getting
30% of their project over a period of 20
years so it's going to be as Amy just
mentioned to me 12th each
year so that after seven years whatever
that one 20th adds up to that's what
they'd have to repay to the state
pursuant to current
building Aid which requires any Public
School receives monies for construction
or renovation and they close this down
and if there's not some kind of an
exemption issued by the state
board they have to pay it back right and
the and the the public school district
has um access to resources after after a
shutdown um you know in the in the case
of a chartered public school where the
um where a
um
dissolution voluntary or involuntary
dissolution event um May um maybe
because of bankruptcy there's there's
you know probably not any assets left to
distribute so so uh um I mean the
bankruptcy court would handle the um you
know clearing of any leans or
mortgages and uh once that's done you
know it will be you know the office
supply place will be there with their
hands open the state will be with their
hands open but there's no more assets
left and and I think that's a concern
from
uh represent Celli thank you there still
very probably are some physical assets
computers desks Furniture Etc um and uh
have to remember that um as we heard in
the I don't know what the name of the
committee was the uh um dissolution the
charter dissolution yeah committee
committee um the Department of Justice
you'll see a a written testimony that I
handed out from the Department of
Justice uh charitable trust division
about their involvement with all this
and they get involved um uh and require
as part of the Articles of agreement of
any nonprofit including Charters um a
dissolution
agreement um which is um probably more
comprehensive than um what is in the uh
uh Charter School
application um under current state state
law RSA
2922 it's which is the Department of
Justice uh Roman 3 says the provisions
for disposition of corporate Assets in
the event of dissolution of the
corporation including the
prioritization of rights of shareholders
and members to corporate
assets
so and you'll see in the document that
um the Char the charitable trust
division gets involved when there is
such a uh dissolution such a
bankruptcy uh they are involved um as
the
primary um state agency in that legal
process
the uh I looked at the state of
Massachusetts Department of Education
and secondary education regarding
charter school closing
procedures and they have written clearly
in their's enlarged bold type here the
school may not dispose of any fixed
assets until de that's Department of
Education uh education Elementary
secondary or whatever has approved the
asset disposition plan so that's why I
tried to copy that material into this um
fixed assets so I'm we're only talking
about so they wouldn't be able to dump
off any other fixed assets which could
be anything from property to buildings
to equipment to
Furniture um and some of that's
described in federal accounting law a
regulation
but what I think Massachusetts is saying
that they
can't uh see may not dispose of any
fixed assets until the department down
there has gotten
their Equity back out of
that facility or their portion which
they've contributed
um but I think I hear you saying what
are the components of this plan to
ensure that um there's going to be or
and also to ensure that there's going to
be the capability of
providing those seven years or whatever
years worth of state aid they've
received but beyond that I'm not really
too concerned because that's not part of
this particular process the State
Building Aid it would be other things
dealing with the what represent cordelli
has mentioned
chairs and
desks well the chairs and desks those
are fixed assets
equipment building property but that's
not gon that's not going to add up I
mean real estate is where the is where
the asset
lies you know it's not with
the so if they own their building
they're going to try to get rid of it
somehow they may sell
it or they may you know it might be
taken from them because they're owing
other people money well so yeah that's
what I'm saying so so the the um you
know the proposal here is that is that
um a charter would get 30% of its
construction
costs covered through building AIDS so
70% of those construction costs are
coming from other you know access to
other resources most likely through a
mortgage Bond and um
and so when it comes to dispose of the
um the asset
um you know that will be the first part
that
gets gets gets taken care of and and
yeah Ian like Banks like to make sure
that that uh that homeowners have some
skin in the
game mhm so would would not then the
legisl that sentence that I read from
Massachusetts here School may not
dispose of any fixed assets until Dee
has approved the asset disposition plan
that's great if you've got if you've got
assets remaining after everybody else
that's ahead of the head of the state
has has has has had their leads paid off
mortgage paid off stuff like that you
know I'm just saying that by by the time
you get down to this
there's um unlikely to be much value
left is it possible put the state being
repaid first before all those others you
could but then you run into exactly what
Mike Mike said which is absolutely true
that that a bank is not going to want to
be in the number two position they're
not going to want to be in the number
two
one represent Celli um but as I read
before from
um current Statute in the Department of
Justice charitable trusts the
disposition of the
Assets in the
um the provisions for disposition
include the prioritization of Rights of
of shareholders and members to those
assets so if um the state is made U
priority in terms of recouping the
amount of school building Aid um to date
given to that uh nonprofit then I I
don't see where the problem
is if we prioritize the state at the top
of that y
yeah with that language and modifying it
we could put ourselves at the top of the
the repay
payback and that's in the disposition
plan if then uh right the the bank reads
that disposition plan says we don't like
it we're not going to provide you any
support for the
70% and that would be that it and then
that the deal is done right there but if
they agree to that and realizing that
what's going to have to be paid back is
really not a heck of a lot of money
really when you look at it if you're
talking about a project that's um let's
say it's a $1.52 million project which
is probably Way Beyond a lot of the
charter schools are going to get at
30% and so the state portion would be
that $2
million and that it's going to be paid
off to the back to the the charter
school over a period of 20 years and
they're going to get that
12th and that because the 2 million is
30% of the total cost they're going to
get 12th of two 2 million each year so
how much is APPA say seven
years what what's you know there's not a
hell of a lot of money there but we've
incurred on the state the tail
though for that is that correct
Amy
other words you have bank roll so much
money for that tail right right pay that
every year correct but we wouldn't um so
with your example so that's $2 million
let's say was that was that was their
award the department would be paying
$100,000 to them every year for 20 years
if they went bankrupt or closed after
year five the state would have invested
$500,000 um and the argument it sounds
like is that it would be difficult to
get that $500,000 back that may or may
not be true U but then we would have had
money set aside but the charger School
wouldn't have any ability to tap into
that we would just roll that back into
um the building Aid fund should one
exist um so um the only other point I
think is important to remember um with
this conversation is that there's
there's lease Aid which is a lease Aid
to to charter schools that pays every
year towards
it's like rent so I mean one way to look
at this I think that disposition
language was really
important from my perspective the
disposition language is very very
important if you're going to pay them
like you pay the public district schools
and give them all the money upfront but
that's not what this bill does it pays
them over a 20-year period so
essentially you're paying them in a
similar structure to lease Aid you're
never ever going to recoup a back so for
me in my my perspective is the
disillusion
Clause isn't
necessarily important um for me anyway
the way I look at it because it's just
like lease Aid
um you know we we have a cap on lease
Aid uh of $50,000 a year and you know if
they close in 5 years we're never going
to get that lease Aid back um so similar
to this structure now if you were to
change structure and put that all up
front where you're giving them the $2
million up front absolutely because it
could close next year and the state
would be out all of their money um
that's at least my perspective of it but
to answer your question if they close in
five years short term we have that tail
we just take that money and we put it
back into the fund that's not a problem
at
all
okay further anything else of uh Amy
right
now represent Dr per me
no
okay okay go
ahead well we're still on 354 yeah thank
you okay I agree subject thank you Mr
chairman I just want to make sure that
we are not missing something that we
heard a long time ago in this bill which
is what representative Mooney said was a
current contradiction in the law and
make sure that we have settled that in
some way or not and to refresh your
memory it was that uh RSA 184 in one
section says that school Charter Public
Charter Schools don't get money if they
don't own their building that's taken
care of on page six it is last last line
right above above the effective
date okay it's
repealed perfect y thank you represent
leus yes on the non disolution part of
it we were talking about um paying the
5% of the El eligible Grant and doing it
over 20 years um and I had asked how
much more that ends up
costing so for example for a three
million loan if you have if you have 3%
% rate it's 740,000
extra interest and if it's a 6% loan
it's $ 1.6
million of extra interest so yes we're
protecting the
state by not paying out that much but on
the other hand we're costing the charter
school an awful lot of money in extra
interest well that's why we went to the
80% Upfront for the frer public school
exactly and the 20% upon completion
exactly and so that was the rationale
right and and and it and the rationale
still holds for Charter
Schools but this bill's not treating the
charter schools the same I know and
we're looking at this bill that's why
I'm pointing it out and but this is the
way it was presented to us by
representative Mooney I
know with that payment scheme yes
represent Bel
thank you Mr chair uh and just to follow
up on the testimony we just heard plus
what um rep leus had to say it does seem
like that if we were to put the state in
a position of first to be recouping
their uh funds and thereby probably
cutting them off from access to private
funds because Banks don't want to be
second position it seems like this on
the whole would be doing more harm than
good so I think if we were going to move
forward with this it's something we
would want to
either not demand that the state be in
first payer um because again these are
these are public schools they're all
public schools come with some risk to
the state for the very minimum perhaps
some sort of a proportionality
arrangement for receiving uh
payout further discussion
so where are we going to go with this
thing do we have to modify it to explain
more
about um how how the state makes
up for the money or how the charter
school is going to pay back what they
owe the state if it closes
or we'd leave it the way it is with that
sentence there on page on line 13 14 15
on page
six which is basically very similar to
what they
have with
masses or do we give
the authority to the department State
Board of Education to develop through Ru
making the process for
or you what are the what are the
components and what's the criteria for
that disposition plan I don't
know that could get pretty convoluted
too
so we're going to have a conversation
probably on the 13th if we don't try to
get a little bit of you know amending
language
now if
not how many people are supportive of
Charter Public Schools getting building
a okay that's you how many are
not so it kind of looks like it's going
to go right down party
line so it'll come out one of those 10
10 votes and we'll have to hack it out
on the floor looks like that's where
we're
going well what we need then is an
amendment yeah we need an amendment
because what we've got here is the
amendment which I thought we could
probably get more support for obviously
it's to me this is boiling down
to some folks just not wanting to give
building a to Charter
Schools whatever the rational is that's
what it's it's coming down
to so it's okay to send building a to
one form of public school but it's not
okay to send building a to another
Public
School
so yeah so so I you know I think it's
pretty clear particularly in the um in
the report in the memo from the charal
trust unit that um Char of schools of
New Hampshire let's see required to
register uh organized as voluntary
corporations um so they're not um
they're not they're not public they're
they're private corporations under
501c3 so so I think there's very much
distinction between um uh supporting
public school districts which are which
are um paid for by New Hampshire
taxpayers and using New Hampshire
taxpayer dollars to support that and
supporting private corporations uh uh
facilities which are not owned by uh and
are not paid for by New Hampshire
taxpayers so I think I think there's
there's a very clear difference between
these two types of
Institutions and not to mention that
we've got a $250 million backlog or
something like that in um in requests
for um for um State Building aid from
public school
districts it's okay
to provide them up to a Max of $50,000
year for
leasing but we're not going to provide
anything for building which is a
probably when you have ownership there's
better care facilities there's more
ownership in
it I guess we're gonna have to have this
debate on the house
floor yes represent cascaden um my
stumbling block is really that um the
public school
districts um have to have the support of
the
voters and Charters don't they don't
have to wait for the voters to decide
whether they renovate or build or
whatever they
do so that's that's one of my stumbling
blocks and then this whole issue of
building Aid no matter what who it's
for is the
backlog and the money is just not enough
for anybody to do anything substantial
other than what three projects if that
or two I mean it's a lot of work to get
ready for a building Aid application to
begin with
MH it's the
system per cordelli thank you I would
say it's a lot of work um for charter
schools to apply for their
Charter um a lot of work even more
because you have to do U curriculum
evaluations and how your curriculum
compares to the state standards um Etc
and in terms of um
requirements um you know Public Schools
depend um on the
voters um however Charter Schools depend
on parents wanting to enroll their
children there and if parents don't want
to enroll their children there for any
reason the charter will close so it's um
even more of a requirement for Charter
Schools if they want to survive to meet
the needs of
students is there any more discussion
here on
354 okay we're going to close 354 down
and take up the last bill which we
[Music]
have
and that
is5 and I do have a hand out here in
this one
too get one put right
there
what I did I simply took 155 assets
introduced and deleted areas which we
disced discussed before um we can
quickly go through this we should be
able to get this I think done in about
five
minutes well let's see if we're right
okay okay um and just briefly explaining
it uh this was presented Remember by
Steve applebe to us from doe he
recommended that number seven be
scratched that's no longer
needed okay so that's page
one oh yeah on p on line three to be the
same as the chancellor the community
college system where they have New
Hampshire or design we'd add or design
for the University
system and for five as
well on the next page um where it said
at the top the commissioner shall on on
well there not not mine's not numbered
with lines but uh up at the top there uh
four lines down e the commissioner sh
there was some discussion whether we
should have may but if you had May then
we had to change some other things so
it's recommended we keep the Sha there
and eliminate number four down
below and then renumber going
thereafter and then scratch out
everything that has to do with the shity
indentification on the postsecondary
career Schools starting at the bottom of
the page to see all the lines out that
second half the bill is
gone effective date Remains the
Same that would be the if we're
agreeable we can get an amendment made
with this in
place everybody good with it so we're
done in two minutes three
minutes
good I'm going to just hand out to
everybody here 266 that changes for 266
s SP 266 we're not meeting again but I'm
just giving it to you so you'll have
it
um it has the one change in it where we
inserted some
language I'll give it to you so you can
see it
it's basically what was given last
time the only change to it is on page
three it's around in there's a box going
around
it it's about disclosing student data to
the you know by the testing agency
testing
entity that's the
only only change above what was brought
to us by Nate green and Caitlyn Davis
everything else is by by
them I still have concerns about that
graduation rate being knocked down
to what is it
67% used to be 69% for two consecutive
years it's down to
67% yes there is that's why it's been
left yes this is all these changes are
due to that Sr
plan so that's just informational for
you I'm going to get an amendment made
with these
changes
okay so there are a few bills I've seen
there that I think we should be able to
agree
upon and then there going to be some 10
tens so that's it for today appreciate
everybody coming back get this thing
done yeah yeah yeah good I guess we're
adjourned good you want to stay Margaret
no no I'm good
than